la la séance est ouverte mes chers
collègues vous vous rappelez que nous
avons présenté en a été présenté à ce à
cette commission le rapport établi par
Michel Tabarot et Bruno fou sur les
relations entre la France et l'Amérique
et l'Afrique pardon mon Dieu le 8
novembre
2023 et nous avions tout à fait
considéré que cet excellent rapport qui
avait recueilli qui avait suscité un
débat très intéressant dans notre
commission que cet excellent rapport
était un acte inaugural et que nous
devions absolument poursuivre notre
réflexion sur cette relation
franco-africaine à la fois très riche
très tumultueuse et
et et très essentielle pour pour
l'avenir et et
donc j'ai proposé
euh au bureau notamment et je crois que
l'idée a été vraiment très très
largement plébiscitée par chacun de
commencer ce cycle d'approfondissement
en en invitant Monsieur Lionel zinzou
qui est qui a de nombreuses qualités
dont la moindre pour moi n'est pas qu'il
est un ami personnel donc c'est quand
même une qualité importante mais au-delà
de ça je trouve que Monsieur euh que
Lionel zinzou avec lequel je participe
souvent à des colloes des réflexions et
cetera à sur la question africaine des
vues
extraordinairement intéressantes
stimulante originale et dont nous
gagnons à
bénéficier monsieur zinzou est fondateur
et partenaire managéial de South bridge
il est président de la Fondation
Terranova et de la Société des Amis du
Musée Branly jacqueschirac il est
également et ça n'est pas quelque chose
de négligeable pour ceux qui nous
occupent aujourd'hui ancien Premier
ministre du Bénin il a été chef du
gouvernement du Bénin entre 2015 et de
2015 à 2016 donc véritablement je crois
que c'est un
interlocuteur parfaitement
euh parfaitement euh adapté pour
inaugurer euh ce cyle alors c'est une
grande joie mon cher Lionel
de vous accueillir dans cette commission
votre histoire votre parcours personnel
vos attaches tant en France qu'en
Afrique de même que vos éminentes
compétences et qualités intellectuelles
font de vous comme je viens de le dire
un intervenant plus que désigné tout
désigné pour éclairer cette notre
commission sur le positionnement que
doit prendre la France face au nouveaux
défis africains alors je ne vais pas
euh je ne me sens pas capable de de de
de
d'introduire plus longtemps sur le fond
la question la véritable introduction
elle a été posée par le rapport de nos
deux collègues madame Tabarot est ici
Monsieur fou est retenu et m'a demandé
de l'excuser par ses
responsabilités
de dans l'assemblée de la francophone
l'assemblé parlementaire de la
Francophonie qui le retient aujourd'hui
à Bruxelles
mais je il m'a assuré et j'en suis sûr
qu'il regarderait avec beaucoup
d'intérêt notre nos conversations et les
échange les l'intervention que vous
ferez devant nous en tout cas cette
introduction elle est donc posée par
notre rapport donc je crois maintenant
que ce que nous allons faire c'est vous
écouter cher Lionel zinzou vous parlez
on dit combien de temps monsieur entre
entre entre un quart d'heure et 25
minutes voilà entre un qu vous êtes euh
vous êtes libre cher Lionel entre un
quart d'heure et et et 25 minutes
ensuite les représentant de chaque
groupe un représentant par groupe vous
posera une question vous fera une
déclaration dans un délai de 2 minutes
et demi vous vous efforcerez de répondre
dans le même lapse de temps évidemment
j'ai beaucoup moins d'autorité sur vous
que sur mes collègues j'en ai très peu
sur mes collègues à vrai dire euh donc
ça ça vous voyez l'étendu de mon drame
et ensuite ceux qui ne représenteront
pas les groupes et qui auront une
question à poser à titre personnel
interviendront une minute et vous
répondrez aussi dans un délai de de même
ordre et puis ensuite évidemment à la
fin vous conclurez dans les termes que
vous voudrez donc vous aurez à travers
l'introduction les réponses au groupe
les réponses au particulier la
conclusion vous aurez toutes les
possibilités de dire tout ce que vous
tout ce que vous avez envie de dire à à
notre commission qui a certainement
grand besoin de d'être éclairé sur un
ensemble de choses concernant l'Afrique
car nous sommes bien conscients que nous
vivons un un passage euh oui nous vivons
un passage d'une certaine idée de la
politique française en Afrique à une
autre idée d'une certaine idée de
l'Afrique et de son développement à une
autre idée vécu par eux par les
Africains comme elle est vécu par nous
et nous manquons certainement
aujourd'hui beaucoup de repère et ces
premiers repères au-delà du rapport que
que nous avons adopté ces premiers
repères c'est à vous que nous les
demandons Monsieur zinzou Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame les vice-présidentes
madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés je suis
d'abord très honoré d'être devant vous
et intimidé d'être devant vous et donc
merci beaucoup de de cette
invitation peut-être juste pour dire
d'où je parle parce qu'évidemment j'ai
mes propres biais dans l'analyse de la
relation entre l'Afrique et la France
puisque étant citoyen français né en
France de parents français mon père
d'origine daoméenne qu'on dit
aujourd'hui
béninoise ayant lui-même mérité la
nationalité française de mon grand-père
donc on est français
dans la branche africaine depuis
1920 et ma mère est et sa voyarde donc
elle est française depuis
1860ou
plust exactement et donc pour moi la
relation entre la France et l'Afrique
c'est la relation entre le l'OM gauche
et l'OM droit du cerveau si vous voulez
c'est une question forcément intime et
par ailleurs je suis fonctionnaire
français d'extraction puisque je suis
aggé l'université j'étais économiste
j'étais enseignant à l'École norale
Supérieure de la rue d'ulme et euh
ensuite j'ai fait une carrière privée
dans un groupe français industriel qui
s'appelle Danon et dans un groupe
financier deux groupes financiers
français l'un le la groupe la banque
rootchi et compagni où j'étais associé
gérant et paribba affaires industriell
dont j'étais le président donc je suis
tout de même assez français dans mon
expérience néanmoins mon oncle est é
président de la République du daomet
dans les années 60 et au Bénin j'ai
essayé de créer une entreprise j'ai créé
une fondation culturelle et malgré de
grands efforts pour ne pas rejoindre le
gouvernement j'ai fini par céder mes
devoirs civies et donc j'ai
effectivement été Premier ministre de la
République du Bénin brièvement et
candidat à l'élection présidentielle ce
qui permet d'avoir
avec nos peuples évidemment une relation
que vous connaissez bien qui me paraît
essentiel ma présence devant vous
aujourd'hui montre que je n'ai pas été
élu président de la République du Bénin
le Bénin esttant un pays
démocratique je peux encore être citoyen
actif dans mon pays mais mais mais je
n'en suis plus un responsable public
donc c'est si vous voulez une espèce de
de de de vie comme ça en miroir entre la
France et et l'Afrique alors évidemment
ça crée de nombreux billets mais un tout
petit peu de d'expérience je voudrais
d'abord dire ma gratit au rapporteur et
votre commission parce que je pense que
ce ce rapport était
nécessaire bienvenu dans le temps et je
m'associe à beaucoup de ces
recommandations franchement et notamment
je suis très sensible au fait que vous
souhaitez qu'il y ait une politique
africaine je pense que la formule à
agadougu du président de la République
en
2017 il n'y a plus de politique
africaine était probablement comme il a
dit hier soir parlant de quelqu'un
d'autre peut-être un peu mal à
droite alors j'ai une grande proximité
que le Président de la République donc
beaucoup de d'amitié je je ne le
critiquerai pas en profondeur mais je
pense que c'était pas la bonne
expression je pense que vous insistez
beaucoup notamment quand vous parlez
d'être public au développement et quand
vous parlez de l'fd sur la nécessité
d'un portage
politique vous insistez beaucoup sur les
besoins de connaissance intime du
terrain qu'on avait rassemblé dans les
équipes de la rue Monsieur qu il y avait
un ministère de la
Coopération moi je partage entièrement
cette idée je pense que les sujets entre
Afrique et Europe au-delà de la France
sont vraiment important pour l'avenir
économiquement du point de vue des
échanges de population culturellement et
cetera et donc je pense que ça mérite
d'être mieux identifié mieux porté
politiquement ça je je crois que c'est
une des des choses pour lesquelles moi
je je vais vraiment tout à fait dans
dans la même direction que que que vous
et je me félicite que vous l'ayez que
vous l'ayez dit je vous remercie aussi
d'avoir ouvert ce rapport par des
considérations
démographiques parce que je pense que la
démographie la compréhension de la
démographie africaine c'est
déterminant économiquement et
politiquement j'ajouterai juste à ce que
vous avez euh fait dans votre tableau de
la démographie africaine que vous
présentez comme un moteur de
croissance deux petites choses la
première c'est oui on est un continent
jeune mais ce qui est le plus
intéressant c'est pas tellement qu'on
soit jeune au Bénin l'âge médian c'est
17 ans et demi ce qui est intéressant
c'est que nous n'avons pas encore de
Senior il y a la population de plus de
65 ans moyenne dans le continent c'est 5
% de la population donc moi je suis dans
les 5 % c'est vraiment nous sommes un
très petit quota en France ça va en
France vous compensez nous sommes
sensible à vos
efforts mais qu'est-ce qui est en train
de nous arriver est en train de nous
arriver quelque chose qui était arrivé à
la Chine il y a 50 ans et qui
aujourd'hui arrive à l'Inde c'est-à-dire
que nous avons et nous allons avoir
parce que nous avons de moins en moins
d'enfants parce que la révolution
démographique fait que la fécondité
baisse dans tous les pays d'Afrique
alors elle part de haut mais enfin elle
baisse partout nous allons avoir la
population très vite dans une génération
la plus nombreuse au monde de jeunes
actifs c'est la situation de l'Inde
d'aujourd'hui ce fut
avant le vieillissement de de la Chine
un atout considérable de l'économie
chinoise donc oui la démographie est
fondamentale parce que nous allons avoir
la meilleure pyramide des âges d'un
point de vue économique celle qui dégage
le plus d'épargne qui crée le plus de
vitalité qui crée le plus de capacité de
d'innovation pas encore beaucoup de
personnes âgées de moins en moins
d'inactifs parce qu'ils ne sont pas
encore d'âge actifs et donc de plus en
plus d'actifs on est dans la situation
inverse notamment pour nos mécanismes de
protection sociale demain de l'Europe où
vous avez de plus en plus d'inactif à la
charge d'actif ça c'est déterminant donc
je peut-être ajouter cet élément de
pyramide des âges et un deuxième élément
c'est que beaucoup de choses est
concentré sur le contrôle des naissances
la maîtrise de la
fertilité la fécondité en
réalité même les pays d'Afrique qui ont
très peu d'enfants la Tunisie a le même
nombre d'enfants que ce que Linc vient
d'expliquer de la France d'aujourd'hui
1,7 enfants c'est-à-dire ce que quelque
chose qui ne permet pas le
renouvellement de la population
tunisienne et maintenant le Maroc
l'Algérie sont parmi les premiers à
avoir des indicateurs quasi européens de
fécondité et pourtant la population
tunisienne augmente pourquoi parce que
le vrai moteur en Afrique de la
démographie c'est l'augmentation de
l'espérance de
vie ce n'est pas que nous avons des
excès de naissance c'est que nous avons
de moins en moins de mortalité avant un
recul même si on a les pires indicateurs
mondiaux de mortalité ils sont beaucoup
de
beaucoup plus encourageant en 2024 qu'
il y a simplement 10 ans l'espérance de
vie voyez prenez des
pays qui sont traumatisés comme les pays
du Sahel au nigerre au Mali je vérifier
dans les chiffres de la Banque
mondiale il se trouve que le le Mali est
en guerre depuis
2007 une façon aigu depuis 2012
l'opération Cerval est de
2013 le Mali dans les 10 dernières
années a gagné 10 ans d'espérance de vie
ce que ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que même des pays qu'on les présente
comme failis et qui sont en guerre sont
dans une situation dans laquelle il y a
des progrès d'éducation il y a des
progrès d'autonomie des femmes il y a
des progrès de santé publique il y a des
progrès de ration nutritionnelle
bref le Mali qui était à l'indépendance
en
1960 un pays où il y avait 28 ans
d'espérance de vie à la naissance est
aujourd'hui un pays on est autour de 62
ans d'espérance de vie donc si vous
voulez dans la démographie il y a des
éléments que vous avez très bien mis en
lumière j'ajouterai juste ces deux-là
qui sont peut-être les plus déterminants
et les plus positifs je vous remercie
aussi d'avoir en
réalité défini un peu toutes les
nouvelles directions vous avez beaucoup
insisté sur les nouvelles bases sur
lesquelles construire une relation plus
confiante plus positive et vous avez
beaucoup peu insister sur des sujets
humains sur des sujets
culturels sur des
changements des
approfondissements dans l'efficacité de
l'aide publique au développement enfin
en réalité vous avez fait dans vos
recommandations
euh au fond à partir de de de pilote
d'expérience vous avez réussi à montrer
que c'était possible d'avoir une
relation de plus en plus riche et je
trouve que c'est le côté positif du et
très utile du du du rapport et puis vous
êtes aussi
euh de nombreux nombreuses reprises dans
l'insistance sur les besoins de
meilleures connaissances alors vous en
parlez pour le personnel diplomatique
pour le personnel d'aide publique au
développement je crois d'ailleurs que
vous faites confiance au militaire pour
être parmi les plus compétents sur le le
terrain mais enfin grosso modo les
aspects cognitifs les aspects de
connaissance quelque chose que vous
mettez beaucoup en avant je trouve que
c'est fondamental dans la relation
franco-africaine il y a quelque chose
qui affaiblit la France c'est une sorte
de
perdition cognitive on ne connaît pas
l'Afrique notamment sur le terrain
économique c'est frappant si vous
chercher de la recherche économique on
est plus fort à mon avis dans les
domaines culturels
académique très fort dans les domaine de
santé bon dans le domaine économique par
exemple il y a des vrais obstacles
épistémiologiques c'estàd que la la
description ou la perception ou la
réputation des économies africaines sont
en arrêt sur image sur les années 60 70
il n'y a pas de renouvellement de la
connaissance on est très loin derrière
même les États-Unis qui ont pourtant des
relations économiques avec l'Afrique
plus faible que que que celle de
l'Europe nous sommes loin en fait en
terme de vivacité de de de de de notre
oui l'Allemagne c'est un peu c'est un
peu un peu particulier dans géographie
imaginaire de l'Afrique un peu
différente de la nôtre donc il sont
probablement un petit peu plus plus
savant sur la nimiie que que que sur le
Bénin si vous voulez mais encore que
vous insistez sur le fait que il y a en
matière de de d'appui à la démocratie je
crois pas que vous citiez la Fondation
Ebert et la Fondation Conrad adenard
mais c'est c'est très c'était très
frappant cette présence et c'est une
très bonne chose je crois que la France
s créé une fondation pour la démocratie
aussi parce que je vous assure que
l'influence euh auprès de nos
journalistes auprès de nos syndicalistes
auprès de nos élus des deux grandes
fondations SPD et CDU en Afrique c'est
un démultiplicateur de l'influence
allemande puissant et et et et à mon
avis très utile euh aux valeurs au
développement et à la défense des
valeurs euh
démocratiques bon je suis également tout
à fait euh dans dans votre sens et je
trouve qu'il faut le répéter et le
répéter même si déjà Paul Hermelin dans
son rapport l'avait fait euh la
politique des visas est véritablement
quelque chose qui qui qui doit vraiment
faire l'objet de de de changement mais
de changement dans le monde
entier un de mes amis qui était
ambassadeur qui est ambassadeur au
Brésil qui était en en Chine euh il y a
lorsque Monsieur Fabius était euh
ministre d'affaires étrangères
constatant que les consulats en Chine à
Shang il était à shanghï consul général
à shangï constatant que pour entrer dans
la zone Schengen les touristes chinois
principal contingent en Europe les
hommes d'affaires chinois allaient
chercher un visa au consulat général
d'Allemagne et pas de France parce que
en France ça prenait un temps fou
c'était totalement bureaucratique il
fallait envoyer toutes les équipe de
Pékin à shanghï pour faire à la main des
distributions de visa donc si vous
voulez ça ne se passe pas que à Dakar et
à campala si vous voulez quand moi je
suis souvent en Grande-Bretagne quand je
vois une queue de
3h à Knights briridge devant le consulat
français si vous voulez et la même chose
à New York je me dis bon ça me r séine
si vous voulez par rapport à la queue à
côonous donc on a un problème de visage
don je crains qu'il soit
générique il y a peut-être des progrès
mais enfin je crois que vous insistez
beaucoup sur le fait que ça crée des
ressentiments précisément sur cette
élite mobile dont on voudrait faire la
conquête sentimentale je vous assure que
ça pose ça peut poser quand même un
problème de façon générale le
renforcement de la diplomatie alors vous
insistez beaucoup moi j'ai trop d'amis
dans la diplomatie française peut-être
pour être aussi sévère que vous sur le
fait que vous avez une façon de dire il
faut que il y ait une
culture bien plus africaine bien plus
terrain bien plus empathique bien moins
arrogante des des fonctionnaires
français sur le terrain si vous voulez
on a la plus
remarquable diplomatie probablement au
monde
soillophone on a également la en terme
de de de diplomatie
arabophone
franchement une diplomatie assez
exceptionnelle donc je suis pas certain
que il y a
eu qu'il y ait tant de défaut à notre
diplomatie sur le sur le
terrain mais c'est vrai que la politique
française n'est peut-être pas aussi
claire et donc ils ont un petit peu de
de mal à à le servir et plus ils
auraient de moyens horizonons de moins
en moins vous allez peut-être me dire
que désormais il recommen en avoir un
petit peu plus grâce à cette commission
grâce à cette commission et d'ailleurs
je me félicite d'avoir entendu mon ami
madame colonac expliquer que désormais
il y aura un concours d'Orient où on
aurait des épreuves de peull et de
mendingue et cetera mais mais enfin bon
mais grosso modo je partage tout à fait
le constat tout en faisant hommage à la
diplomatie française quand même de ces
de ces
qualités il y a une chose qui m'a amusé
c'est que vous n'avez pas beaucoup parlé
de la
DGSE dans le personnel alors je me suis
dit ça doit être sûrement une prudence
ou un code au fondut pas nécessaire de
faire des commentaires sur la DGS dans
un rapport
d'information parce que moi je ne crois
pas du tout que la DGSE soit faible en
Afrique je crois pas que ces
interactions avec la diplomatie
française soit soit faible je pense
qu'il y a un certain nombre en il y a
des échanges de personnels entre la DGSE
et la diplomatie française donc je pense
qu'ils sont légitimes
euh je pense que elle avait tout vu
venir en réalité dans les rejet au au
Sahel je vous rappelle aussi sur les
coups d'État qu'il y avait eu un peu de
scandale avec une note du Centre
d'Analyse prévision du kedory qu'on
avait appelé la les effet pangolin
c'était en
plein confinement donc c'est une note
d'avril qui qui était devenue publique
alors qu'elle n'était pastait pas
destinée à l'être l'ffet pangolin c'est
on nous annonçait non seulement qu'il y
aurait des coups d'État liés à
l'affaiblissement des sociétés civiles
des
économies regain de pauvreté sera créé
par la pandémie qui a été aggravé
ensuite par l'inflation alimentaire liée
à l'Ukraine
et qui allait jusqu'à pratiquement
désigner les pays où ça aurait ça se
passerait la seule chose c'est que cette
note qui annonçait la fragilité d'un
certain nombre de régimes où les où les
régimes étai peut-être avait peut-être
duré un peu trop longtemps ou n'avait
pas pratiqué nécessairement tout ce
qu'il fallait en en matière
démocratique mais seule erreur c'est que
elle pensait que ce serait la société
civile
les intellectuels la diaspora et les
églises qui allaient fomenter les
changements de régime bon en réalité
quand même plus efficace à changer les
régimes nos officiers d'ailleurs formé
je ne sais pas pourquoi l'école de
guerre je vous signale que des grandes
écoles françaises celle qui a désormais
le plus de chefs d'État en exercice dans
le monde c'est l'école de
guerre c'est également sacir kidan euh
ça n'est plus euh ça n'est pas l'École
normale supérieure ou l'École
polytechnique parce que je regrette j'ai
professeur pendant 10 ans quand qui donc
je suis innocent de cette de ce
crime non mais c'est tellement vrai que
si vous voulez par exemple il y a un
pays le Togo qui aujourdhui aujourd'hui
joue un peu un rôle de
médiateur et qui est en train d'essayer
de faire tomber les sanctions sur le
Niger et de trouver un compromis avec la
jeinte du Niger qui est également le
passeur de messag de de paix entre le
Mali et le reste de la CDAO pour une
raison simple c'est que l'aide de camp
du président Forni simbe et l'ami parce
qu'il est le promotionnaire du
lieutenantcolonel Go président de la
transition du Mali à l'école de guerre
si vous voulez donc je crois que à
plusieurs reprises vous dites que la
France a renoncer à former les
élites je suis pas sûr si vous voulez
vous avez des vous savez
le ceci est enregistré ah oui alors donc
je vais je vais être précis donc je ne
vais pas dire ce que j'aurais dit si je
n'avais pas été enregistré c'estàd que
le Maroc est quand même gouverné par des
polytechniciens des Centraliens des
ingénieurs des pont quoi gro que
l'Afrique francophone subsaharienne a
vraiment des élites qui sont parfois
allé en plus à
Harvard ou à Warton il y en a quand même
très peu qui viennent de Moscou de
shangï donc je suis pas sûr qu'on est
complètementmoins vous ne l'avez pas
dit voilà donc enfin il y a des gens
pour le dire alors on
va mais ajoutez-y les militaires quand
même comme ça vous verrez
statistiquement la France n'a pas
renoncé à à tout à fait à formullit donc
tout ça c'est c'est pour vous dire
combien je pense que votre rapport est
pertinent et nécessaire alors je vais
juste vous dire quatre choses que bien
volontiers j'aurais souhaité que tout
est présent hein mais que vous
vlez
développassier premièrement les
entreprises françaises
elles sont peu évoquées et je vous
assure qu'elles sont quand même un
pilier très important de la
présence de la France en
Afrique et d'ailleurs ça colore un
certain nombre de chiffres que vous
utilisez et qui sont à comprendre dans
le contexte spécialement français par
exemple vous évoquez une baisse de part
de marché de la France sur tous les
marchés africains par rapport à la Chine
en très grande progression à d'autres
pays européens et cetera
oui mais la France a doublé le nombre
d'entreprises filiales d'entreprises
française entre 2010 et 2020 qui sont
installés en Afrique oui mais il y a
4000 entreprises françaises à la Chambre
de commerce franco-marocaine au Maroc et
vous retrouvez ça dans énormément de
pays et notment dans les pays
francophones mais pas que dans les pays
francophones et ça ça veut dire que la
France exporte peut-être moins vers
l'Afrique que d'autres pays parce
qu'elle fabrique plus parce qu'elle est
implantée et faisons tout petit peu
attention les pars de marché vous les
analyser dans les statistiques douinière
mais que faites-vous des usines de tangé
de Renault de Kenitra de Peugeot de
cadouna de de Peugeot qui qui
apparaissent dans les exportations
marocaines puisque ce sont des
ou nigérian puisque ce sont des
véhicules qui sont destinés d'abord à
l'Europe d'ailleurs c sont du Maroc ou
aux autres pays africains faire un tout
petit peu attention à cela nos parts de
marché ne sont pas comparables par
exemple les Pays-Bas vous nous dites les
par Pays-Bas l'Allemagne progresse c'est
vrai c'est évident mais il n'y a
pas vous n'avez pas des chiffres on n'a
pas des chiffres ça on en a besoin de ce
que représente les entreprises
françaises en tant qu'elles produisent
localement je vous rappelle quelque
chose dont je crois j'imagine votre
commission est totalement consciente la
France a une particularité historique
moi ce que j'enseigné à l'école
supérieur c'est l'histoire
économique ça c'est séculaire la France
est le pays qui achète le plus d'actifs
productif à l'étranger c'est comme ça
juste après les États-Unis si vous
rapportez ça au PIB c'est la nous sommes
des champions de multinationales
achetant des actifs productifs à
l'étranger donc vous dites la
Belgique progresse fortement en euh en
Afrique dans les marchés mais qui a
acheté la Société Générale du Belgique
qui possède l'Union minière du hokatanga
qui a acheté les centrales nucléaires et
tractébelle
éctrobelle sont très présents en Afrique
ngj
suè mais qui est la première
banque qui a acheté notamment la
belellegolaise et cetera bon c'est la
BNP donc faire très très attention la
France devrait revendiquer une partie
des parts de marché européenes
simplement parce que ce sont des
entreprises françaises qui ont
investi donc faire très attention ce
sont des chiffres brut qui servent à
exacerber un sentiment de déclin en
faisant l'impasse sur le fait que
l'économie française n'est pas
l'économie belge elle n'est pas
l'économie allemande ça n'est pas de la
même nature et donc c'est pour moi c'est
très important vous trouvez que la
Turquie progresse trop vite par rapport
à un pays comme la France mais la
Turquie exporte des voitures françaises
la Roumanie fait partie des pays qui
vont le plus vite en croissance en
Afrique on pourrait dire vous vous
rendez compte quel défi la France croit
beaucoup moins vite que la Roumanie oui
enfin l'exorte essentiellement des Dacia
qui appartiennent à Renault si vous
voulez faire un tout petit peu attention
à l'utilisation des chiffres pour ça je
dis il y a des obstacles
épistémologiques donc est-ce que les
entreprises sont assez présentes dans le
rapport c'est une très grande force de
la France et alors vous utilisez aussi
un un un monitor du Sian mes amis du
Sian donc le syndicat patronal qui
montre grosso modo que y compris dans
les pays francophone désormais les
élites préfèrent en terme d'image
positive d'un pays les États-Unis le
Canada l'Allemagne et cetera selon les
pays et que la France est toujours
léguer alors j'ai énormément d'amis et
et d'amitié au
Sian cet indicateur ne vaut absolument
rien d'un point de vue méthodologique
l'échantillon n'est absolument pas
significatif et puisque vous êtes allé
sur le terrain et beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent très bien
l'Afrique évidemment que les seules
entreprises étrangères dans les pays
francophones significativ que vous
preniez orange Castel qui a quand même
37 1000 salariés en Afrique si vous
voulez et cetera mais mais mais je
pourrais citer EDF mais je pourrais
citer NJ mais je pourrais cité total
énergie et cetera et cetera et cetera la
seule expérience des élites économiques
des pays francophones sont les
entreprises française et je vous assure
que quand un salarié a le choix de
trouver un emploi dans entreprise
française dans un pays comme le mien
plutôt que dans une entreprise chinoise
mais mais si vous voulez ou Amérique
américaine il aurait du mal à en trouver
pour être sincère le Canada c'est bien
mais le Canada ça n'existe pas en
Afrique sur le terrain si vous voulez je
vous assure qu'il n'y a pas il y a pas
une minute
d'hésitation les entreprises européennes
de façon générale français en
particulier ont l'image de respecter le
droit du travail un certain nombre
notamment les entreprises côé qui sont
obligé de d'en rendre compte et donc cet
indicateur sert à nourrir le pessimisme
et le déclinisme français mais à rien
d'autre alors je pense que le can
continue de le produire pour obtenir
plus de soutien de la République
française aux entreprises françaises en
disant regardez on ne nous aime plus
vous savez d'ailleurs toutes les
statistiques sur
l'amour sont souvent difficiles à
déconner mais alors les gens qui
préfèrent le Canada à la France en Côte
d'Ivoire si vous voulez on doit quand
même les compter STATIS
sur les doigts de d'une
main la deuxième chose qui me frappe
c'est votre chapitre passionnant sur la
géopolitique la puissance française
effacée par toute une série d'ennemis
alors en tant qu'Africain si vous voulez
mon regard est différent en tant que
Français je je je vous comprends
parfaitement parce que votre rapport
sous cet angle est un résumé des peurs
françaises vous avez des périls un péril
jaune terrible la Chine est en train de
de écraser d'un point de vue
d'investissement et de et de d'échang
commerciaux alors sur l'investissement
le stock d'actifs productifs de la
République populaire de CH de Chine est
inférieur à celui du Portugal donc faut
faire attention le fait de construire
des chemins faire des infrastructures
des stades et le siège de l'Union
africaine c'est formidable ça fait des
images le stock de capital productif
pour des raisons historiques est encore
pour l'instant inférieur en stock
Portugal donc je ne parle pas des deux
grands pays en stock de capital que sont
la Grande-Bretagne et la France pour des
raisons historiques évidentes quant aux
échanges je m'amuse du fait que vous
expliquez que il y a 20 ans la Chine
c'était moins de 3 milliards d'échange
avec l'Afrique
subsaharienne et qu'aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup plus ça é multiplié par
20 c'est pas loin de 60 milliards de
dollars
oui mais mettez cela en miroir avec
l'Europe il y a 20 ans c'était moins de
200 milliards
d'échang d'importation
chinoise en l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui c'est 650 milliards il y a
une très grande différence entre
l'Europe et l'Afrique subsaharienne dans
la relation commerciale avec la Chine
c'est que l'Afrique est en équilibre et
pas en
déficit je ne vais pas apprendre à votre
commission que le déficit de l'Union
européenne vis-à-vis de la Chine est de
390 milliards de dollars le déficit 2020
23 estimé de l'Afrique vis-à-vis de la
Chine est de 2 milliards on est quelque
part entre 60 et 58 entre importation et
exportation bon l'Afrique subsaharienne
étant beaucoup moins importante que la
l'Afrique du Sud et le Maghreb maschrek
que vous ne traitez pas dans dans le
dans le rapport et donc effectivement
les les les chiffres de la Chine sont de
l'ordre 250 milliards avec l'ensemble de
l'Afrique mais la la Chine ne
s'intéresse pas encore au marché
africain donc si vous avez si vous
transmettez à travers ce rapport la peur
que la Chine déstabilise toutes les
parts de marché il faut être encore plus
pessimiste alors car la
Chine lorsque la Chine
s'éveillera à l'intérêt du marché
africain là il y aura de quoi trembler
parce que pour l'instant nous servons en
Afrique
de fournisseur de matières premières et
nous avons très très peu d'intérêt des
entreprises chinoises à nous vendre
alors on nous vend évidemment du
matériel de télécom de chemin de fer du
textile et des jouets mais si vous
voulez nous ne sommes pas nous nous
servons
pas de déboucher à la Chine mais ça va
arriver parce que le continent a quand
même aujourd'hui un PIB en pouvoir
d'achat qui représente laad de
l'économie française l'économie
allemande donc ça va commencer à
intéresser les entreprises chinoises
mais ça n'est pas encore fait donc de
deux choses une où on veut être
optimiste aujourd'hui la Chine n'est pas
une menace pour l'Union européenne en
Afrique mais si on veut être pessimiste
alors oui il faut bien penser qu'à un
moment donné nous allons finir par
intéresser la Chine mais pour l'instant
nous sommes entre l'excédent et
l'équilibre avec la Chine en Afrique ça
n'a rien à voir et donc en réalité ce
sont nos matières premières qu'on
transforme dans l'usine du monde qui est
la Chine pour la demande française et
allemande c'est ça le
triangle c'est pas pour pour nous
envahir donc toutes les tout le discours
sur la
néocolonialisation chinoise est
dérisoire à mon avis deuxè peur la peur
russe bon alors la Russie grosso modo
d'après Vladimir Poutine on a pas des
statistiques autres que la parole du
président ces 20 milliards probablement
surestimés sur l'ensemble du continent
d'exportation de la Russie gonflé
aujourd'hui par les prix ocarbure du blé
des
engrais et les
importations de la Russie venant
d'Afrique c'est 2 milliards c'est que ça
n'existe pas c'est 2
milliards j' tire juste votre attention
puis je vais monsieur le Président aller
très très vite à la fin parce que je
vois que j'ai abusé mais NAB pas sur la
peur russe je crois qu'il faut il faut
il faut être un tout petit peu un tout
petit peu prudent pour l'instant la
Russie est l'ombre de l'ombre de ce
quiétait l'Union
soviétique et à l'époque si vous voulez
il me semble 1991 ce n'était pas une
obsession européenne que la menace
menace russe si vous voulez il faut
quand même voir le les rapports les
rapport de force si vous voulez l'Europe
absorbe une partie considérable des
exportations de l'Afrique et la Russie
aucune donc si vous voulez c'est une
relation très très très asymétrique
alors je passe sur la Turquie l'Iran et
cetera et sur les États-Unis j'attire
votre attention sur le fait que les
États-Unis ont considérablement baissé
en flux de commerce avec l'Afrique pour
une raison très simple c'est qu'ils sont
devenus exporteur net
d'hydrocarbures et que l'essentiel de
leur commerce était fait jusque en 1900
jusquen
2018 de
d'importer de des hydrocarbures le
nigerria l'Angola tout ça ont dû
repivoter vers l'Inde la Chine et
l'Europe puisqu'ils ne peuvent plus euh
au fond exporter vers les États-Unis
l'Algérie très important fournisseur de
gaz fournit l'Europe et c'est d'ailleurs
essentiel aujourd'hui et plus du tout
les États-Unis puisque les États-Unis
sont exportateurs nets c'est un
changement radical donc les États-Unis
ont un
discours qui
se ai de la
France mais et et et et beaucoup de
chefs d'État sont intéressés à venir à
Washington parler avec le président
Biden il y a pas de doute simplement
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
la relation économique entre les
États-Unis et l'Afrique est faible
surtout pour l'Afrique subsaharienne
entre Nord et Sud et surtout en déclin
alors elle recommence à monter un peu
mais en déclin fort ce qui n'est
jamaisarriver à l'Europe et pas non plus
à la
France 3è et dernier avantdernier point
il n'y a pas c'est peut-être là-dessus
que que vous m'interrogerez il n'y a pas
de rejet de la France par l'opinion en
Afrique je suis
désolé d'aller
contre une idée
reçue et d'ailleurs personne ne le
mesure pourquoi parce que simplement il
faut nous faire
l'omô d'admettre que comme tout le monde
nous avons comme le monde entier une
opinion publique et cette opinion
publique elle est traversée par des
courants différents et je ne vais pas
nier un instant notamment dans la
jeunesse que nous ayons des des
souverainistes que nous ayons des
nationalistes que nous ayons des
panafricanistes comme il
s'appelle évidemment et qui sont des
activistes
et qui dans les pays francophones
n'attaque pas que tout l'accident mais
plus spécifiquement la France parce que
c'est ce qu'il fait connaissent et
souvent d'ailleurs ils sont de
nationalité française
entre autres par exemple kimiseba on a
découvert qu'il était béninois quand il
a fallu l'expulser du Sénégal où est-ce
qu'on l'envoie on peut l'envoyer qu'en
France au Bénin parce qu'il est bénino
français bon la France ça paraissait pas
paraissit pas une très bonne idée
puisque c'est le contempteur de du franç
FAA et c'est le le plus légèrement
stipendié par Wagner c'est peut-être le
plus l'activiste le plus violent contre
la France donc il l' envoyé au Bénin qui
a découvert qu'il était béninois bon
mais il est surtout français si vous
voulez faire très attention à cela mais
mais nous avons le droit d'avoir nos
extrémistes je veux dire personne ne
dirait de la France je crois qu'en
France il y a plus de
souverainistes que en Afrique
subsaharienne pour être sincère je crois
qu'en France il y a peut-être même je
sais pas si quiconque se se se
reconnaîtrait peut-être plus de
populiste que chez nous si vous voulez
mais enfin si vous voulez prenez par
exemple des attaques que la France prend
pour des attaques contre la France des
attaques contre Total énergie au
Mozambique en Ouganda en Tanzanie où il
y a une énorme controverse c'est une
controverse des ONG françaises
contre Total énergie les attentes des
ONG africaines sur le
développement du pétrole du gaz et
cetera aussi bien en Namibie qui va
devenir le deuxème producteur du
continent qu'au Mozambique que en
Ouganda mais les attentes des ONG
africaines elles sont très très grandes
et le soutien est écrasant en majorité
dans nos populations sur ce genre
d'investissement qui par ailleurs sont
investissements français que vous ne
mentionnez pas dans le rapport mais qui
sont historiquement les plus grands
investissements jamais faits en Afrique
tout secteur confondu toute géographie
confondu donc faire un tout petit peu
attention au fait que nous avons une
opinion publique et on trouvera toujours
500 personnes pour faire le siège de
l'ambassade de France à niamet enfin il
y a 22 millions de Nigériens il y en a
pas il y en a pas il y en a pas 22000 on
trouvera toujours de quoi remplir un
stade parce par que nous avons une
opinion publique nous avons des progrès
de la démocratie malgré les apparences
et et de l'expression et des réseaux
sociaux mais c'est une toute petite
minorité moi quand j'étais candidat à la
présidence de la République sur les
réseaux sociaux j'apparaissais comme un
blanc alors moi je suis très habitué à
être un blanc en Afrique puisque je suis
très habitué à être un noir en France si
vous voulez donc je pr une fois qu'on
est une fois qu'on a appris que voilà ça
ça ça ne pose pas grand problème au peut
vivre avec ça donc j'étais le SAL blanc
envoyé par François Holland comme
gouverneur des
colonies c'est
pas un récit intéressant en fait je
pense qu'il y a bien 10 % de la
population du Bénin qui considérait que
j'étais en effet un blanc envoyé par la
France comme gouverneur des colonies
mais sur les réseaux sociaux ça
représentait peut-être 80 % de
l'expression d'opposition euh et dans la
prés du ciel et et et comme premier
ministre si vous voulez faire très
attention il y a des il y a des miroirs
déformants et les armées sont en train
de faire une étude dans le cadre des
opérations de
contre-influence sur d'où viennent les
contenus très largement fait de fake
news sur le la France ses péchés ces
scandales et donc tout ce qui nourrit le
rejet de la France et bien là j'attire
votre attention et c'est vraiment mon
dernier point mais sur le fait que les
diasporas voilà les
diasporas
sont le pour plus de la moitié des
contenus utilisés en Afrique et qui
circulent en Afrique et qui reviennent
dans la presse
français les diasporas sont en réalité
les promoteurs de ces fake news faire
très attention je vous assure mon
témoignage c'est que même quand on dit
qu'il y a un
de la France je crois pas qu'il y a de
rejet des Français ça se verrait s'il y
avait des rejets de français si vous
voulez il y a une très grande différence
entre ces deux
concepts mais la presse française et
l'opinion française est incroyablement
sensible à des images et pas à la
critique des images vous avez 500
personnes devant l'ambassade de France à
niamet on abaisse le drapeau au départ
du dernier soldat enfin il y a jamais eu
de base française ni à Niamé ni à
agadougu ni à bamaco jamais donc on
n'est pas en train de de de chasser de
leur base les militaires français de
Djibouti de Libreville d'Abidjan ou de
Dakar il y en a jamais il se trouve
qu'il y a eu des résolutions qui ont
demandé à la France de venir dans ces
pays à partir du moment où les autorités
publiques ne veulent pas les troupes
français partent c'est pas une expulsion
par rapport à des décennies de présence
pas du tout mais donc
vous abaissez le drapeau et on a
l'impression qu'on quitte
l'Afghanistan mais pas du tout ou le
Vietnam vous voulez parce que c'est la
même image enfin à niamet il y a 1200
personnes qui ont jamais été là avant
deux dernières années c'est quand même
très différent de quitter l'Afghanistan
mais c'est des images à très très fort
contenu l'ambassadeur de France que vous
avez auditionné au Mali a été expulsé
par le gouvernement malien on étit
pendant la présidentielle française deux
dames très importantes dans la vie
politique française dont chacune pouvait
penser qu'elle serait présidente de la
République madame pcrè madame Marine Le
Pen ont aussitôt répondu sur les médias
il faut expulser l'ambassadeur du Mali
en France mais il avait été expulsé 2
ans avant et la France avait refusé
d'accréditer aucun autre donc faire très
attention il y a il y a des comme cela
mais ces symboles il faut il
fautut critiquer puis les traiter en
image il y a un imaginaire du rejet
français qui est une peur française mais
s'il y a quelque chose qui devrait
inquiéter la représentation nationale ça
n'est pas la Russie ça n'est pas la
Chine ça n'est pas la Turquie ce sont
les diaspora en France parce que vous
avez une diaspora à laquelle moi je
ressemble si vous
voulez qui est au service de la relation
franco-africaine et qui peut être un
atout et c'est celle dont vous parlez
dans le rapport en disant utilisons les
diasporas nommons des binationaux et
cetera ou des descendants africains et
il se trouve que
celle-là d'un point de vue de catégorie
socio-professionnelle
elle est cment certainement acquise mais
pas du tout celle des cités pas du tout
et en fait là où il y a un risque de
rejet français c'est si la perception
des discriminations ou de l'inégalité
des chances continue ça croit alors là
effectivement cela va polluer très
sérieusement le fait que nos enfants en
France soi inconfortable pour la
majorité d'entre eux s'ils se perçoivent
comme discriminés voilà quelque chose
qui serait grave pour la relation
franco-africaine tout le reste à mon
avis relève plutôt de l'imaginaire et le
président de la République française a
eu tout à fait raison de mettre beaucoup
l'accent sur la politique culturelle les
restitutions d'objet d'art le
développement de la créativité la cité
de
villercotret parce que en réalité cette
relation est très immatérielle et si sur
le terrain immatériel culturel et de
l'imaginaire qu'il faut se départir de
l'idée et que la France décline en
Afrique et que la France est rejeté de
l'Afrique je vous
remercie bien j'ai vous avez démontré
parfaitement mon ma totale ma totale
incapacité à maîtriser les horaires de
mon invité et je m'en félicite parce que
je crois que tout le monde conviendra
que ce que vous avez dit était
absolument passionnant je dois dire qu'
a une seule chose sur lequel vous avez
clairement
menti un mensonge grave vous avez dit
que vous étiez désolé de mettre en cause
les idées reçues vous avez mis en cause
les idées reçues mais vous n'étiez
absolument pas désolé de le faire je
tiens à le dire de la façon la plus
formelle et nous non plus car c'est
évidemment très stimulant d'abord je
pense que Madame Tabarot a certainement
comme nous tous apprécié la qualité de
votre lecture du rapport qui a été
adopté par cette par ce cette commission
et les observations extrêmement fines
que vous avez faites je crois que tout
le monde a a vraiment été passionné
alors maintenant les groupes vont
s'exprimer et la première à s'exprimer
et la députée madame lacraffie au nom du
groupe Renaissance madame lacrafie qui
comme vous le savez est assez largement
député enfin député d'une large partie
euh de euh euh des Français euh de
d'Afrique
euh chers collègues c'est à vous de
prendre la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je suis très heureuse d'être
parmi vous et j'ai envie de vous
souhaiter une excellente année à toutes
et à tous et une année de Pai vous avez
2 minutes et demi hein très bien très
bien mes chers collègues permettez-moi
tout d'abord de vous souhaiter encore
une fois une année en fait j'ai envie de
dire de paix souhaitons-nous
collectivement la paix la sérénité pour
2024 même si je ne crains que ce soit un
peu pieux mais on a le droit de rêver je
suis très heureuse de m'adresser à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre puisque
monsieur Zinsou a occupé cette fonction
au Bénin euh pays de la circonscription
don dont j'ai l'honneur et le grand
grand privilège d'être élu mais c'est
surtout en tant que fin analy de
l'Afrique et de nos relations avec le
continent ici africain que je souhaite
l'interroger la relation entre la France
et l'Afrique sont à l'honneur en ce
moment en général il s'agit de jeter
l'eau probre sur l'action du Président
de la République et plus généralement
sur notre pays qu'il s'agisse des usines
à troll de puissance étrangère ou de
certaines oppositions ici en France
chacun se fait l'apôtre d'un déclinisme
qui voudrait que notre pays perde pied
sur le continent africain qu'il se paye
sa présence coloniale passée et
néocoloniale actuel tandis que les
peuples africains réclameraient son
départ je m'inscris ici en faux je pense
que c'est pas la première fois que je le
dis et vous avez l'habitude de
l'entendre dans cette commission je
m'inscris ici en faux par rapport à ce
récit certes très bien ficelé qui arrive
à convaincre une certaine jeunesse qui
sert aussi bien et je le répète et je ne
cesserai de le répéter certaines
puissances étrangères hostiles que nos
oppositions en tout cas certaines de nos
oppositions j'ai développé le fond de ma
pensée lors du débat de novembre dernier
dans l'hémicycle sur les relations
afrique-fance je considère que nous
n'avons pas à rougir du bilan de la
politique menée depuis 7 ans sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République notre pays s'est en effet
attaché à parler davantage aux jeunes
aux diaspora aux entrepr preneurs aux
artistes il il est le premier à avoir
engagé une démarche de restitution de BI
culturels alors que ça fait je crois des
décennies que certains pays africains
nous le demandent le président Macron
est le premier à avoir restitué ses
biens au Sénégal notamment et les
trésors royaux d'abomé plus récemment le
président a clairement défini la logique
partenariale qu'il appelle de ses vœux
et qu'il est et qui est en réalité celle
qui prévaut depuis de nombreuses années
et j'ai envie de dire depuis le le
discours de wagadouu je vois moi sur le
terrain même dans des pays soumis à une
intense propagande des populations qui
ne sont jamais je dis bien jamais
heureuse de nous voir partir jamais
heureuse de voir tous nos soldats partir
et j'ai de très nombreux exemples même
au Mali il y a certes cette réalité la
France a été mise en difficulté ces
derniers mois dans certains pays
d'Afrique jusqu'à s'en retirer oh là là
mon dieu mon dieu mais son jensy bien il
s'agit bien de quat pays sur 150 sur 54
pardon et et ma question et je vais
arriver à la question le kedoré a pris
conscience peut-être un peu tard et se
mobilise aujourd'hui sur ce ce discours
contre la désinformation monsieur zinou
vous l'avez dit à la fin de de de votre
propos comment vous analyz ce discours
et surtout surtout quelle réalité il
englobe on a une partie de la réponse
mais le contrer on a commencé à le faire
est-ce que vous avez des pistes pour
contrer ce
discours très bien c'est voilà une
question qui a l'avantage d'être très
direct merci madame la députée monsieur
monsieur
zinzou merci merci madame la
députée je crois qu'il y a une prise de
conscience en effet du fait que il faut
traiter l'imaginaire
l'immatériel la
communication et essayer de se
rapprocher un peu de la
réalité peut-être de poursuivre un peu
la
vérité contre des entreprises désormais
bien identifiées comme des entreprises
volontaires de propagande
mensongère euh l'avantage dans le
caractère euh indiscret dans le
caractère euh ostentatoire dans
l'hostilité de Monsieur Prigogine si
vous voulez c'est que on sait maintenant
très dans le détail euh comment
fonctionnent les usines de fake news de
Wagner
en plus c'est c'est c'est grossier en
réalité quand vous quand vous regardez
tout ce qu'on reçoit sur internet sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est c'est c'est
absolument c'est ça ça n'est pas très
c'est efficace mais ça n'est pas
extrêmement sophistiqué disons bon donc
si vous voulez il y a désormais et au
ministère des armées et au ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères des
gens en charge de la contre-influence
l'audiovisuel public vous en parlez dans
le
rapport il a le défaut de ses qualités
c'està dire on
écoute aussi bien France 24 qui est un
énorme succès aussi bien en français
qu'en anglais qu'en arabe peut-être
encore plus influent en arabe qu'en
français etfi je quand vous allez à la
matinale de de France Inter vous êtes
sûr d'avoir 4 millions et demi de de
d'auditeurs quand vous allez à la MA de
vous êtes sûr d'en avoir 24 millions
c'est quand même assez impressionnant si
vous voulez c'est la même chose
d'ailleurs pour la BBC bon donc si vous
voulez mais il se trouve que ce sont des
médias intègres et donc il ne diffusent
pas de la contreinfluence au bénéfice de
la France sont juste intègres pourquoi
est-ce que les gens les écoutent
tellement en Afrique BBC RFI pour avoir
de l'information
vraie mais si on a l'ination vraie on a
une information totale qui respecte le
contrat ctoire et cetera donc on sent
une légère nostalgie dans le rapport
l'audiovisuel français devrait mieux
servir la propagande pas la propagande
l'influence française mais c'est pas
possible n sommes dans un pays de droit
si vous voulez et donc effectivement là
il y a une asymétrie mais on ne va pas
se mettre au niveau de la production de
fake news parce que les fake news
impressionne les gens mais ils sont
faits ces fake
news c'est fait pour le opinion
française en France voilà ça est c'est
c'est beaucoup moins impactant en
Afrique
même merci alors je tiens à vous dire
que j'ai beaucoup de indépendamment des
groupes j'ai beaucoup de demandes de
parole donc il faut vraiment se tenir
dans les dans les limites je le dis à la
fois pour les parlementaires et
évidemment pour Lionel zinzou qui dans
Don
l'éloquence nous séduit trop et me rend
difficile
de la contenir dans des délais précis
euh pour le rassemblement national
Monsieur Michel
Guignot
merci merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur zinzou bonjour et
meilleur vœux merci pour votre exposé en
tant qu'ancien Premier ministre du Bénin
et président de la Société des Amis du
Musée Branly Jacques Chirac vous êtes
particulièrement concerné par les enjeux
de restitution d'œuvres d'art au profit
des pays africains et je pense que cette
thématique fait partie des grands enjeux
qui attendent la France pour les années
à venir d'autant plus qu'il apparaît
avec la création du Musée d'Art
Contemporain d'ouida par votre fille que
l'art est un sujet qui vous tient à cœur
le 9 novembre 2021 avec plus d'un siècle
de séjour en France 26 œuvres
constituant le butin de guerre du
général dos et et propriété de l'État
sont restitué au Bénin cette encein
cette entorse au principe d'Ali au
d'inaliénabilité a été le fruit de
plusieurs années de négociations entre
votre pays et le nôtre au point de vue
national les rapports Savoie et Martinez
préparés sur demande du Président de la
République se contredisent dans leurs
propos même s'ils préparent tous deux à
l'arrivée d'une loi réformant le
principe
d'inaliénabilité des collections
publiques les biens dont la France est
aujourd'hui propriétaire car j'exclus de
mon propos tous les biens détenus hors
collection publique font partie
également notre histoire il ne s'agit
pas d'œuf que nous avons réalisé mais
elle n'en reste pas moins inspirante
pour le public français restauré dans
les meilleures conditions possible et
mise en avant dans le respect des
cultures et des peuples d'origine
certaines de ces œuvres détenues dans
nos musées ont fait l'objet d'une
protection particulière de la part de
nos services des œuvres d'art sont
issues de peuples qui ont été aniliés
par des conflits locaux et nos musées
permettent de faire perdurer leur
histoire sans prendre un parti
localement polémique et je noterai enf
propos qu'il est précisé dans le rapport
Martinez que les uvres restitué ne
reviennent pas toujours dans leur lieux
d'origine qu'en est-il des pays qui ont
été créés après la création de l'œuvre
ou après leur attribution à l'état
français et au-delà de ces
considérations c'est nos fondamentaux
légaux qui sont amenés à être
questionnés toute mutation qu'elle soit
vente ou donation pourrait être remise
en cause c'est le principe même du
transfert de propriété qui est donc
remis en cause pensez-vous que enfin on
peut considérer tout de même qu'il est
indéniable que la France possède bien
sûr à ce jour des trésors d'origine
étrangère pensez-vous que les pays
africains pourront admettre que la
France a en tout cas permis la
préservation et la conservation de ces
œuvres jusqu'à ce jour monsieur le
Président je vous remercie monsieur le
député monsieur Zinsou monsieur le
député merci beaucoup d'attirer
l'attention sur ce sujet qui me tient en
effet très à cœur je vous précise que je
ne suis plus président de la Société des
Amis de j'étais quelques années du musée
Jacques Chirac je suis administrateur du
musée Jacques
Chirac monsieur le député je dois
d'abord remercier les députés du
rassemblement national d'avoir voté la
loi qui permis qui a permis la
restitution au Bénin puisque l'Assemblée
nationale a voté pour la restitution au
Sénégal et au Bénin à l'un
la loi présentée par Madame bachot à
l'unanimité donc je pense que votre
question porte sur certaines des
modalités
mais je vous félicite d'avoir fait
partie de l'unanimité sur ce
sujet
deè deè
remarque savez il y a eu nombreuses
polémiques en France sur le fait qu'on
vidait les
musées français alors les collections
publiques du Musée Branly elles ont
aujourd'hui au répertoire
366000 objets pour l'instant on en a
aliéné
27 non mais donné chiffré donc on n pas
encore vidé les euh les musé français 3è
commentaire vous avez tout à fait raison
de poser la question au fond est-ce
qu'on ferait crédit à la France d'avoir
préservé d'avoir conservé dans de très
bonnes conditions
C c'estes trésors nationaux oui et c'est
tellement vrai que le musée sous la
présidence de Monsieur casarerou qui est
un très grand muséologue le nouveau
président du kbrandi comme d'ailleurs
avec Stéphane Martin son créateur qui
l'a précédé à une coopération
remarquable avec les pays africains
notamment pour éblir l'histoire de ces
objets savoir effectivement à quel
royaume de quel royaume il dépendait et
cetera et pour également techniquement
parce que la muséologie vous avez fait
allusion au fait que nous avons créé
deux musées au Bénin dans la Fondation
familiale et ma fille a effectivement
été une influenceuse assez importante de
la loi sur la restitution mais et le
président du Bénin Patrice Talon et
celui qui a écrit à la République
française en disant restituer les objets
il a une réponse négative du président
Hollande positive du président Macron à
ouagadougu en 2017 donc effectivement le
Bénin est assez associé à tout cela si
vous voulez la coopération avec la Côte
d'Ivoire aujourd'hui avec le Sénégal
avec les états est absolument
remarquable en terme anthropologique en
terme muséologique et la France est en
train de faciliter la création de
nouveau musée notamment la FD au Bénin
et c'est absolument déterminant parce
que je crois que c'est ce qui a été le
plus le mieux réussi du premier
quinquena du président de la République
en matière de relation avec l'Afrique
parce que ça jouait sur des choses très
importantes la dignité l'identité même
et ce qui moi m'a frappé c'est que
là-dessus la coopération est totalement
confiante totalement confiante
l'imitation par les Européens de la
France est spectaculaire les Belges les
Allemands il y a que les les
Britanniques qui ont peur de perdre les
fresques pas les fresques oui ils ont
peur peur de l'héritage de l'ordg des
des du
parténant mais enfin la France fait des
émules partout au point où
volontairement les Américains sont en
train de restituer au Nigéria au Bénin
un certain nombre d'œuvres qui avaient
une origine un peu un peu floue c'est
c'est une coopération exemplaire qui
pourrait être l'emblème des coopérations
à très fort contenu de connaissance et
de confiance
voilà
euh FR pour la France
insoumise madame abangoli NAD est à
vous mais je pense ah pardon merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministreinou chers collègues la
croissance économique de l'Afrique
ralenti ces dernières années la Banque
mondiale prévu prévoit pardon en Afrique
sub-saharienne une progression de 2,5 %
en 2023 en baisse de plus de 2 points en
en en 2 ans bien sûr ce chiffre
post-crise covid cache de fortes
inégalités régionales par exemple
l'Afrique de l'Ouest est beaucoup plus
dynamique que l'Afrique de l'Est mais au
total 50 % de la population vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté ainsi le continent est
le premier bénéficiaire de l'APD public
au développement environ 50 milliards
par an selon euh selon l'OCDE monsieur
Zinsou première question en tant que
président d'une banque d'investissement
qui il me semble produit également du
conseil aux États sur quel secteurs les
acteurs privés internationaux
peuvent-ils réellement je dis bien
réellement influer en terme de
développement je pense à la santé à
l'éducation encore au secteur industriel
n a-t-il pas une contradiction imaginer
une complémentariité réelle entre des
fonds d'investissements qui ont leurs
intérêts propres avec les politiques
publiques dont l'APD dans l'intérêt des
peuples comment en réalité est-ce donc
perçu sur le terrain et est-ce que ces
dernières années on constaterait une une
substitution dans dans dans dans dans
dans l'esprit des citoyens entre
gouvernance publique en faillite
réellement et gouvernance privée ce qui
serait pour nous un signe d'échec de
l'aide publique au développement par
ailleurs sur le plan politique comme le
disait Thomas Sankara il faut choisir
entre le champagne pour quelques-uns et
l'eau potable pour tous or sur le plan
politique des logiques de puissance
imposent euh régulièrement de manière
assez constante d'ailleurs des
dominations économiques et politiques à
l'égard des pays les plus pauvres
pendant des décennies la France s
appuyée sur des régimes despotiques pour
assoir son influence sa stratégie
reposait sur une illusion de stabilité
qui sur le temps long a produit de
l'instabilité ces derniers mois ont
montré l'échec de cette lecture de
nombreux régimes issus de coups d'État
aujourd'hui font peu de cas de la
démocratie ils se succèdent ceux
d'aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas forcément
soutenus par la France ce certains
d'hier l'était pourtant à vos yeux
est-il possible de déployer une
stratégie d'APD sans clarifier les
objectifs politiques des relation entre
États africains États occidentaux euh
par en réalité Fermine d'ignorer que ces
relations politiques doivent évoluer et
caricaturer comme certains le font les
oppositions politiques qui pointent ces
contradictions on pointe juste des
contradictions ça ça ne suffit pas
comment enfin dernière question je
promets comment évaluez-vous l'action
des bricks qui laisse
entrendre un objectif de dédolérisation
des économies et cela peut-il selon vous
amplifier la remise en cause du Fran CFA
qui est perçu comme un symbole de domin
nation politique et économique de la
France sur certains États africains
beaucoup de questions je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la dernière
question est évidemment énorme vous
aurez l'occasion sans doute d'y répondre
aussi en réponse à d'autres intervs
merci beaucoup madame la députée pour
ces questions nombreus et et très très
profonde en
réalité il y a une chose qui m'a frappé
dans dans dans votre rapport c'est vous
avez beaucoup parlé des bouleversements
et très bien décrit les bouleversements
de l'économie africaine et les
dynamiques de croissance en en disant au
fond l'Afrique a beaucoup changé et euh
elle devient quelque chose potentiel
très important de croissance pour le
long terme mais la France aussi a
beaucoup changé elle a énormément changé
il faut pas du tout rester en arrêt sur
image la France a aujourd'hui dans la
mondialisation fait des choix très
européen beaucoup développé sa ses
positions en Asie et relativement
moins en Afrique elle a changé les
entreprises par nature qui participent à
l'économie africaine il fut un temps c
des entreprises spécialisé dans ce qui
faisait l'économie de traite mais
aujourd'hui la CFAO vieille maison de
commerce appartient vous le savez à
Toyota et plus du tout entreprise
française la compagnie française de
l'Afrique occidentale est japonaise elle
est très importante elle est japonaise
elle avait absorbé la SCOA donc les
vieilles maisons spécialisées perissac
Morel Prom Morel Prom à Bordeaux Mor le
Prom a vendu toutes ces tous ses actifs
et s'est vendu elle-même à Pertamina
aujourd'hui le deuxième producteur de
pétrole au Gabon c'est les Indonésiens
de la Société Nationale
Pertamina mais les gens continuent à
défiler dans les rues en expliquant
Total Gabon total Congo c'est Pertamina
mais personne connaissant Pertamina les
gens ne voyant pas que la France a
changé et donc la France aujourd'hui
elle est dans sa contribution à la
croissance regardz comme un phare en
agro en foresterie est très adapté à
tout ce qui est
green en matière de technologie et donc
elle a toujours été importante sur le
plan agroalimentaire première industrie
de transformation en Afrique elle est
regardée comme essentielle en énergie à
travers l'action d' DF d'nj
de Total
énergie en
renouvelable aujourd'hui vous savez
qu'en hydrogène autour d'Air Liquide et
tout un ensemble de d'entreprises il y a
de nombreuses initiatives
notamment dans le Maghreb arabe
Mauritanie et
Maroc est importante en
géothermie rien de tout ça n'existait il
y a 20 ans donc c'est pas la même France
elle a ce type de ce type d'atout par
ailleurs il y a des des activités de
venture capital de capital risque qui
sont soutenu en France sur par la France
sur le numérique en
télécom la France coloniale c'est pas
des télécom et de la technologie mais la
Télécom Orange
Free sont des acteurs tout à fait tout à
fait important donc si vous voulez l'eau
suè revient en Afrique Veolia est resté
en Afrique ce sont les deux numéro 2 et
1 mondiaux de l'eau vous voyez donc
c'est ça c'est une une France différente
de l'image de l'imagerie française ce
sont des entreprises internationales
françaises sur des secteurs qui sont
clés pour la transition énergétique clé
pour faire reculer la fin et valoriser
les matières premières donc ça je crois
que et et le l'aide publique au
développement va dans le soutien de même
qu'elle soutient dans le domaine des
industries créatives et du sport des
choses assez innovantes que vous
décrivez dans le rapport et c'est et
tout ça c'est complètement nouveau il ne
faut pas sur l'Afrique rester en arrêt
sur image faut regarder une France
bouleversée des années 24 conclusion
c'est une très bonne conclusion si
voulez je reparlerai à l'occasion oui du
français sur le
français vous aurez l'occasion de le
faire
peut attendre un tout petit peu elle
sera
satisfaite maintenant c'est c'est Madame
Tabarot madame je dois dire que je je ne
peux que vous donner une minute de plus
que les autres en qualité de de
corrapporteur mais n'abusez pas merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président je voulais vous remercier pour
l'intérêt que vous avez porté à notre
rapport et au travail que nous avons
réalisé avec Bruno fou et Anaïs polycarp
sur sur ce sujet qui nous nous intéresse
tous puisqu'il est un un sujet important
à la fois du passé et de l'avenir de de
de la France et et de l'Afrique ou des
Afrique comme certains on ont souhaité
l'appeler je voudrais si vous me le
permettez évoquer quelques points que
vous avez mis en avant dans le cadre de
vos de vos remarques plutôt négatives
sur sur le rapport même si vous avez
salué euh le le travail presque
l'ensemble du travail euh la la
diplomatie la diplomatie loin de nous
l'idée de d'attaquer la diplomatie
française et j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire et je l'ai dit en mon nom je crois
que c'était plus simple pour Monsieur
fou mais que j'étais défavorable à la à
la réforme du qu d'oré parce que je
crois justement que nous avons une une
élite qui est particulièrement bien
formé mais dans le cas spécifique de
l'Afrique nous avons voulu appuyer sur
le fait que ça nécessitait une formation
peut-être encore plus importante pour
avoir ce lien privilégié avec les les
différ en différents pays africains et
tout ça bien entendu avant les
nominations euh nous avons vu de
nombreuses fois où les nominations sont
faites un petit peu au dernier moment on
enlève un diplomate d'un d'un pays ou
d'un continent et et on le nomme
ailleurs on pense qu'un temps de
préparation est est nécessaire et et
utile pour pour avoir les meilleures
relations possibles vous avez parlé de
la formation des élites en nous disant
on en forme encore beaucoup oui mais on
en forme beaucoup moins on en forme
beaucoup moins puisqu'il y a fois moins
de coopérants techniqu et militaire que
dans les années 90 donc on a encore la
possibilité de développer ou peut-être
l'occasion de de le faire un peu plus
que que nous ne le faisons aujourd'hui
sur les entreprises françaises vous nous
avez rappelé à juste titre que les
entreprises françaises à travers
certaines filiales étaient très
présentes c'est vrai que nous n'avons
évoqué que les investissement direct
donc ce qui
identifie les les entreprises françaises
concernant l'Afrique du Nord vous avez
évoqué certains certains chiffres
positifs mais c'est vrai que nous
l'avons sorti de notre présentation
parce qu'on imaginit que ça allait nous
demander encore plusieurs mois de
travaux et et le président aurait été
très agacé de voir notre notre équipe
continuer absolument enfin sur la la
compétition avec les les
pays donc ce ceux qu'on évoque
régulièrement aujourd'hui en en Afrique
la Chine la Russie la Turquie euh nous
les avons euh abordé sous sous un prisme
particulier la Chine par rapport à la
dette et au piège de la dette et de
savoir que un port comme celui du du
Kenya le port de montbasa risque d'être
récupéré par la Chine euh voilà montre
le danger de de de la la façon dont la
la Chine euh a ses ses liens commerciaux
avec euh avec l'Afrique euh sur la
Russie bien entendu euh euh ça n'est pas
euh équilibré au niveau des de de de
d'un équilibre commercial enfin d'une
balance commerciale mais c'est
véritablement pour appuyer sur le fait
sécuritaire et sur la stratégie aussi de
piller un certain nombre de ressources
donc c'est dans cet état d'esprit que
nous l'avons évoqué enfin sur la Turquie
c'est l'aspect religieux l'aspect
culturel que nous avons souhaité évoquer
avec mon collègue Bruno fou concernant
le rejet de la France je je partage euh
au bout oui voilà je partage votre votre
avis sur le fait qu'il y a à la fois euh
des relations qui sont et nous l'avons
vu dans notre déplacement en Côte
d'Ivoire où où il y a une demande de
France et et un regret que la France
n'assume pas sa sa présence en tout cas
c'est son son lien privilégié avec
l'Afrique d'un autre côté vous l'avez
évoqué les diasporas et la diaspora qui
peut être parfois beaucoup plus critique
vis-à-vis de la France et puis on l'a on
l'a vu dans dans certains échanges avec
avec certaines critiques je vrais en
terminer avec la presse c'est un élément
important vous l'avez dit pas de pas de
fake news bien entendu et et c'est
normal la presse française ne peut pas
se permettre de relayer des fake news
mais la presse française peut se
permettre de relayer des informations
positives de ce que la France fait
aujourd'hui en Afrique et c'est la
critique qui a été réaliser en se disant
profitons de ce média de ces médias qui
rentrent réellement en afque pour
pouvoir véhiculer les bons
messages pas vous Laer plus loin c'est
près de 5 minutes oui très bien je
comprends que vous ayez beaucoup de
choses à dire vous avez répondu à à
plein de points j'espère que le monsieur
monsieurzou point par point et reprendre
son propre
exposé oui monsieur le Président je vais
essayer
d'être d'être obéissant madame la
rapporteur entièrement d'accord avec
vous sur la diplomatie je voulais juste
ajouter un élément parce que moi j'ai
travaillé beaucoup avec eux depuis la
France ou depuis l'Afrique je voulais
juste un élément de d'hommage à la
qualité de d'une diplomatie qui je vous
assure en terme linguistique
anthropologique est quand même assez
exceptionnel sur les les élites céit un
peu un clin d'œil si vous voulez faut
rappeler qu'un certain nombre de pays
franc sont dirigés par des élites
formées encore en France et je voulais y
ajouter les militaires parce que je ne
sais pas si la France endosse et assume
comme dirait le président de la
République le fait de de d'avoir formé
des des lieutenants colonels aussi
entreprenant dans certains comme le
président de la Guinée était jusqu'à il
y a quelques mois
euh dans la Légion étrangère officiers
français opér en faire toute leur
carrière en France mais c'était plutôt
un un clin d'œil euh sur les coopérants
alors j'écoute le président de la
répuique française il faut que la France
reste la France je lis la Une de
Libération qui est vieille France faut
pas être trop vieille France si vous
voulez il ne peut pas y avoir 10000
coopérants civils français en Afrique
parce que l'Afrique n'en a pas
besoin parce que aujourd'hui quand vous
avez besoin de compétences d'abord vous
les forz nationalement les universités
les grandes écoles africaines sont
récentes au Bénin on les on a créé
l'Université nationale en 1968 et encore
tous les bailleurs de fonds ont dit on
va pas vous aider car il y a déjà une
université de plein exercice à dakard
mais d'acord c'est à 2000 km et
aujourd'hui il y a 120000 étudiants de
notre pays dans le campus que mon mon
oncle a créé en 1968 au Bénin donc si
vous voulez on forme nos propres élites
et donc on a moins besoin de coopérant
deuxièmement on n pas besoin de
coopérant on a besoin de consultants
d'experts et on n' pas besoin du profil
coopérant sauf peut-être dans
l'éducation et la santé on a besoin
d'enseignant du secondaire d'enseignant
du
supérieur mais on n' pas besoin de
conseiller auprès des ministres parce
que quand on a besoin de conseil on on
s'adresse à des sociétés de conseil
elles peuvent être français vous êtes à
quelques centaines de mètres du BCG qui
a un grand
immeuble de siège à côté de l'Assemblée
nationale on fait appel au BCG on fait
appel à mckinse on fait appel on n pas
besoin de coopérant permanent dédoublant
les fonctions c'est on est on n pas dans
la vieille France je vous assure il y a
pas de polémique sur les contrats des
gouvernements avec mckinse dans nos pays
alors qu'il y en a un petit en France si
j'ai bien compris mais si vous voulez on
on passe par d'autres moyens et on
produit nos propres élites mais j'attire
votre attention sur quelque chose qui
est
intéressant que que font les
États-Unis les États-Unis ont des
ambassades où il y a toujours plus de
personnel donc elle serait un un élément
un argument pour vous que dans les
ambassades de France et qu'est-ce qu'il
y a comme service la NSA la CIA la DEA
parce que le crime organisé on n pas
encore parlé crime
organisé et et beaucoup plus la réalité
du terrorisme que les gens en croisade
de djihad et et donc il y a la la la
drug enforcement agency et le FBI et
d'ailleurs moi je pense que dans les
équilibres entre militaire et
policiers magistrats détachés dans les
ambassades ils sont de plus en plus
nécessaire parce que encore une fois la
France les pays occidentaux sont plus
déstabilisé par les trafics de de drogue
de cigarettes d'êtres humains de faux
médicaments que par des combattants
armés d'une croissade religieuse le
président Bazou insistait toujours
là-dessus les djihadistes ne font pas un
djihad religieux ils font des trafics
qui ont une une importance considérable
les États-Unis le reflèteent mieux dans
leur personnel sur le terrain et ils ont
aussi quelque chose de très intéressant
c'est le PIST corpse
ce sont ces volontaires immergés qui
sont pas coopérants conseiller technique
du ministre des finances mais qui
connaissent le terrain qui sont obligés
d'apprendre les langues vernaculaires et
ça je pense c'est plus intéressant de
même que la coopération médicale ou la
ENF voyez une coopération d'extrême
proximité pour l'action publique de
développement mais les 10000 coopérants
qui étaient en double commande des des
administrations on en a plus besoin en
fait on les a produit et ou sinon on
s'adresse au marché euh des des
consultants même des banquiers
d'affaires maintenant si vous voulez bon
et puis sur la sur la la presse je suis
d'accord mais
euh il faut que la communication du
gouvernement il faut qu même la
communication monsieur le Président de
la de la représentation
nationale diffuse aussi si vous voulez
le le rapport que vous avez fait il faut
trouver les moyens d'y intéresser les
Français que la presse française le
relait on ne relais pas les choses qui
montrent que la France n'est pas en
déclin en Afrique quand bien même vous
l'écrivez tout en disant et c'est en
même temps assez facile de voir les
grandes orientations pour améliorer
cette relation mais est-ce que ça passe
suffisamment et on ne peut pas faire de
la propagande à travers la presse donc
il faut donner assez de respect à
l'Afrique pour je vous dis pas rétablir
dans le monde une page Afrique tous les
ans comme il y en av tous les jours
pardon comme il y en avait une dans le
journal Le Monde sur l'Afrique du temps
de Monsieur de crine si vous voulez il y
a il y a 30 ans ça c'est la vieille
France malheureusement mais il faut
s'organiser au kedorset mais aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale par exemple tout à
l'heure je faisais compliment à Monsieur
le Député du rassemblement national du
vote à l'unanimité y compris des des
députés dans la législature précédente
si vous voulez mais personne le
sait dans la il y a encore tous les
échos sur les restitutions de la
controverse on va vider les musées
français on va va dépouiller les
conservateurs les privés les
collectionneurs privés on va enfin une
espèce
de ils vont ils vont revendre à l'encan
les chef-dœuvres ils sont incapables de
les conserver dans leur musée c'est pas
parce qu'on leur a volé qu'il faut leur
rendre parce que le voleur est un
meilleur conservateur que le
propriétaire vous aviez cette espèce et
mais personne n'a dit l'Assemblée
nationale a voté à l'unanimité vous
voyez et donc c'est pas par la
propagande c'est par la volonté de
parler d'Afrique de développer la
connaissance de l'Afrique et que les
institutions françaises et les
entreprises françaises disent ce
qu'elles font bien c'est 40 % des
résultats de de Total énergie personne
ne le sait la production en Afrique il
faut il faut arriver à ce que la France
fasse savoir
quelle est quand même parmi les
meilleurs partenaires de
l'Afrique je alors écoutez moi j'ai une
constat sociologique c'est que les très
bons invités font les présidents très
malheureux parce que là c'est c'est pas
la peine c'est je peux pas vous
interrompre vous dites des choses
absolument passionnantes mais il est
clair que nous ne pourrons pas tous
parler si on développe on en a pour
jusqu'à 2h moins le quart donc je pense
que que vous aurez le souci de d'avaler
quelque chose avant les questions et et
donc il faut absolument alors n avons
finir avec les groupe ensuite je serai
obligé je ne pourrais pas donner la
parole à tous ceux qui l'ont demandé à
titre particulier et je vous demande
cher lionels inzou d'essayer vraiment de
contenir vos réponses dans les les 2
minutes et demi qui sont celles de des
des des de ceux qui vous interrogent
même si c'est très difficile et c'est
c'est une une une frustration pour nous
car nous sommes toujours tous très
heureux de vous entendre la parole est
pour le groupe modem à Madame
vichevski merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre merci pour
votre intervention et toutes les
réponses que vous nous faites et merci
surtout de bousculer nos nos idé nos
idées reçues merci de nous inviter à
reconsidérer l'image notamment qui est
qui est la nôtre et merci aussi de me
contredire si dans les questions que je
vous posé il y a des affirmations qui
vous paraissent absolument
décalé nous l'avons nous le savons les
défis de l'Afrique sont à la fois
nombreux et immenses et on n' pas
beaucoup parlé du défi climatique sur
lequel je je souhaite vous poser une
question le réchauffement frappe plus
durement ce continent que le reste de la
planète alors même que la contribution
de l'Afrique à ce phénomène mesuré en
terme d'émission à gaz des gaz à effet
de serre par habitant est très inférieur
à celui des autres continents comment
remédier à cette
injustice défi économique ensuite alors
vous êtes si savant que j'ose à peine
m'exprimer où la où la logique de la
mondialisation pousse l'Afrique à livrer
au reste du monde ses énergies fossiles
et ses métaux rares alors qu'elle ne
paraît pas par ailleurs à même d'assurer
de toujours assurer en tout cas sa
propre souveraineté alimentaire est-ce
qu'il est sage je pense au Kenya de
faire pousser des fleurs destinées à
l'exportation dans un pays menacé par
par la par la famine jusqu'où faut-il
pousser la théorie de l'avantage
comparatif vous avez par ailleurs
largement fait allusion à la démographie
et et j'ai entendu ce que vous nous
disiez de très juste la mortalité
infantile a beaucoup baissé euh bon
grâce au progrès de la médecine mais
parallèlement même si elle baisse la
fécondité des femmes n'a pas diminué
dans des proportions similaires en tout
cas et les démographes peut-être se
trompent-t-il comme nous aussi prévoient
une population de près de 2 milliards
d'habitants en en 250 et de 4 milliards
en 2100 alors comment peut-on imaginer
sa stabilisation sur le continent
africain et est-ce qu'il est encore
pertinent même si je sais qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un avantage comme vous nous l'avez
exprimé est-ce qu'il est encore
pertinent de parler de dividende
démographique la position de la France a
changé la franceafrique est morte depuis
longtemps mais si l'on doit reconsidérer
notre politique d'aide au développement
sur laquelle vous vous êtes exprimer
est-ce qu'on doit aller vers plus
d'intégration de l'Afrique dans
l'économie mondiale ou plutôt
l'aider à renforcer son autonomie merci
Madame la déput j'ai cherché à moins
dépasser que les autres en tout cas
Deven 43 15 mais on est déjà totalement
je vous le dis les les demandes
particulières ne pourront pas être
honorées toutes merci madame la députée
j'ai pas du tout de d'idées reçues dans
ce que vous avez évoqué vous avez tout à
fait raison de de parler de changement
climatique euh l'Afrique est du côté des
solutions et pas des problèmes donc
grosso modo elle représente 18 % de la
population mondial et 2 % entre 2 et 3 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
tiendrait qu'à l'Afrique
le climat de la planète refroidirait si
vous voulez pourquoi parce que on a peu
d'utilisation et notamment la moitié des
ménag les familles n'ont pas accès à
l'électricité par exemple et peu
d'entreprises sont de grandes
consommatrices d'électricité mais
surtout l'Afrique est du côté des
solutions parce que elle a encore des
des terres arabes disponibles elle a les
forêts qui restent parce que l'amazonene
est en train de cesser d'être un puit
la grande le grand puit carbone de la de
la planète et on peut faire beaucoup
pour la reconstitution des forêts en
zone de savane qui sont en fait des des
savanes d'épineux qui sont en fait des
des forêts détruites et ça on peut tout
à fait aujourd'hui avec des modèles
économiques appuyés par des crédits
carbon reforester l'Afrique il y a
beaucoup de projets de ce côté-là et et
puis elle est également maîtresse des
solutions sur les matières premières
critiques parce que en terme de de
graphite en terme de cuivre en terme de
coltan en terme de lithium elle a les
plus grandes réserves mondiales et il y
a d'ailleurs aujourd'hui une course
effrainé pour l'instant sur le podium il
y a plutôt la Chine les États-Unis et
l'Allemagne mais la France n'est pas
complètement absente pour assurer des
développements des investissements dans
ces matières premières qui qui sont
critiques pour les batteries pour
l'automobile pour toute une série de
toute une série de de
production à bas carbone donc oui
l'Afrique est du côté des solutions on a
aujourd'hui en
2024 certaines aversion au risqu lié à
l'ensemble de la crise mondiale qui fait
qu'on ne va pas assez vite en terme de
d'investissement et la France n'est
peut-être pas assez rapide par rapport à
l'Allemagne par rapport par rapport aux
États-Unis dans ce domaine mais vous
avez tout à fait raison
euh l'Afrique va avoir 2 milliards
d'habitants à cause de l'espérance de
vie hein comme nous le le disions vous
disiez on va pas très vite en changement
dans la fécondité c'est le le mouvement
le plus rapide historiquement jamais
observé parce que normalement c'est pas
très plastique l'évolution de la
fécondité pays comme le mien au sud le
plus mondialisé si vous voulez qui a
plus de relation avec le monde il y a
trois enfants par femme au Nord à la
frontière du nigè il y a SEP enfants par
femme et quand on demande aux
populations du Sud combien
souhaitez-vous d'enfants la réponse
c'est 3 et quand on demande aux
populations saéliennees de notre pays
combien désirez-vous d'enfants c'est 10
pourquoi parce que les enfants c'est la
sécurité dans des pays où il y a pas de
prévoyance sociale organisée euh c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est la survie de la
génération ascendante en fait et puis
parce que quand on a 10 enfants on en
perd 6 vous voyez mais c'est c'est vous
avez une dualité incroyable dans les
métropoles africaines on est déjà comme
en Tunisie comme au Maroc comme en
Afrique du Sud en en en en baisse très
forte de la de la fécondité et vous me
demandez qu'est-ce que laapd doit faire
aider ces pays dans leur souveraineté et
dans leur industrialisation oui à
évidence mais surtout elle doit aller
plus vite ce qui est frappant si vous
voulez Barkan est un succès militaire
parce que les parce que les militaires
français monsieur le Cornu l'a dit à
votre représentation nationale à la
tribune il y a quelques
jours mais vous ne pouvez pas être ne
pas être accompagné par des efforts
considérable de créer de l'emploi dans
les pays dans le nord du Mali dans le
nord du du Niger où les djihadistes ou
les trafiquants ou le crime organisé
recrutent il faut absolument des
alternatives des investissements des
créations d'emploi et là l'aide publique
au développement est pas du tout
marginal c'est 40 % du budget du Niger
avant coup d'État 40 % du budget
simplement dans le rabort madame la
rapporteur vous dites souvent les gens
demandent qu'on passe à l'acte les gens
demandent qu'on passe à l'action c'est
bien de faire des discours
oui et de les faire dans le tempo et
c'est pour ça aussi que vous avez
infiniment raison de dire il faut un
portage politique parce que un Ministre
en
charge il a besoin d'action parce que
son tempo est un tempo rapide un
fonctionnaire de l'aide publique il est
il il est il est là pour pour toujours
d'une certaine manière il n'a pas ce ce
ce tempo qui est fondamental il faut
désormais aller vite dans la coopération
civile c'est très important et même dans
les réponses excusez-moi il faut aller
vite le tempo le tempo le tempo c'est
Monsieur Alain David pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre nous
poursuivons avec votre audition une
série de de débats tant en commission
que dans l'hémicycle votre éclairage
alimente donc une réflexion qui commence
à sét auffer qui permet de mieux
appréhender les raisons profondes de
cette évolution accéléré entre par
exemple le lancement de l'opération cal
en 2013 salué par les populations et la
série récente de coups d'État qui
s'accompagnait dans ce dans ce secteur
et et la remise en cause de la présence
française dans cette partie de l'Afrique
on avait beaucoup dit que on ne
gagnerait jamais la lutte contre le
terrorisme avec les armes mais au
contraire avec un un accompagnement tout
autre cela a été rappelé un partenariat
renouvelé avec les pays africain et donc
impérieusement nécessaire chaque pays
avec ses particularismes doit concentrer
l'attention de notre diplomatie et nous
devons combattre l'idée d'un Occident
égoïste qui ne nourrit des accords
qu'entre pays développés et uvrer au
contraire un réel
multilatéralisme la France possède
encore des atouts du professionnel et de
l'excellence de nos diplomates à l'atout
formidable de la Francophonie de notre
audiovisuel extérieur respecté à
l'attractivité encore importante de
notre enseignement secondaire dans un
certain nombre de pays africains il
convient donc d'aborder la relation avec
les pays africains avec optimisme mais
également avec vigilance en ne
reproduisant pas les récentes erreurs et
en tenant compte surtout du nouvel ordre
global né du conflit en Ukraine et du
réembrasement au Proche-Orient vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure à juste titre de
l'opinion publique quel est le sentiment
qui
prédomine pardon par rapport à cette
nouvelle donne internationale et quels
en sont les conséquences
immédiates merci monsieur le député
monsieur zinzou oui
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
monsieur le député je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous la France conserve
des atouts très importants encore une
fois moi je trouve que il y a beaucoup
d'aspects immatériels qui sont
essentiels si vous voulez notamment les
atouts français sur la langue que vous
venez de
d'évoquer il y a aucun doute que les
pays
anglophones reçoivent de façon démesurée
par rapport au pays francophones des
investissements directs parce que le
fait de parler en anglais de faire les
contrats en anglais et de travailler en
common law c'est quelque chose qui
rapproche les grands investisseurs
institutionnels beaucoup plus du Ghana
que la Côte d'Ivoire c'est deux
économies qui se ressemblent énormément
mais l'une reçoit 10 fois plus
d'investissement étranger en moyenne
période le Ghana parce que se sert
utilement de la langue la culture la
culture juridique euh britannique enfin
anglaise et donc ça c'est des atouts
vraiment très importants et le travail
sur la Francophonie est à mon avis très
important il y a plus de locuteeurs
francophones désormais en Afrique de
beaucoup que en Europe et en France donc
ça c'est très important c'est pareil
pour la coopération en santé la
coopération culturel muséal et cetera et
cetera on a on a pris plusieurs
exemples cela dit euh vous posez une
question à la fin sur sur l'opinion
publique sur si vous
voulez nous
avons des opinions publiques contrastées
parce que au Mali je crois que la
majorité de la population est très en
faveur de la jeinte voulait se
débarrasser du régime civil
précédent pense que la France avait des
liens particuliers parce que il est vrai
que le président
IBK était membre de l'international
socialiste avait une discussion avec
Monsieur François
Hollande de collègu à l'intérieur de de
l'international socialiste euh et cetera
donc il y a une identification assez
forte du régime d'beca qui pourtant au
total un progrès démocratique par
rapport au passé mais enfin qui était
perçu comme défaillant sur certaines
dimensions peut-être même celle de
l'intégrité
ou ou ou sur son rejet des Accords
d'Alger mais c'est très bien documenté
dans le rapport toutes les tout
l'historique des Accords d'Alger donc je
vous apprends rien et la France
notamment la France de gauche monsieur
monsieur députés vous êtes conscient que
le président issoufo au Niger le
président ibka au Mali le président
alfhaondé en Guinée ont été des membres
du Parti socialiste français et dans
leur période d'exil puisque la France
tout à l'heure quelqu'un disait est-ce
que la France madame la députée
disz-vous dialogue suffisamment avec les
opposants mais les opposants démocrates
sont réfugiés des pays francophones sont
réfugiés en France en fait hein non
c'est pas vous qui avais posé la
question de est-ce que est-ce que on a
trop de d'affinité avec les dictateurs
bon donc si vous voulez mais la
situation de la Guinée la situation du
Mali n'a rien à voir avec celle du Gabon
donc faut pas faut pas tout mélanger
mais il est probable qu'au Mali la
majorité de la population il y a un
sondage allemand qui a été fait par la
coopération allemande qui semble le
montrer et je pense que Monsieur Goa va
être va devenir un civil et va être élu
président de la République du Malie il y
a pas un très grand suspense parce que
là c'est toute l'histoire le président
de la République euh insiste énormément
sur le mémoriel avec l'Algérie avec le
Rwanda avec l'histoire l'histoire au
Mali c'est que les populations
négro-africaines du Mali se sont
toujours méfiés des affinités entre la
France et les populations
arabo arabe et arabophone du nord du
Mali en clair l'idée que il y a une
histoire séculaire entre les toireg et
les Français a toujours créé un problème
avec les population majoritaire du
peuple des rrives du fleuve Niger si
vous voulez tout ça rentre dans dans
dans dans l'imaginaire donc ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'opinion publique
gabonnaise vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et donc ce sont des situations
différentes il y a entre Mali et France
une hisire his soire très très
différente des pays côtiers il y a une
longue fraternité avec la
Russie on a formé pour le coup beaucoup
des élites maliennes en en en Russie il
y a beaucoup de couples mixtes et donc
le dialogue est complètement différent
avec la Russie au Gabon il y a pas un
seul russophone enfin je m'excuse pour
les russophones gabonnais que j'oublie
mais vous voyez bon la Guinée aussi a eu
des relations compliquées avec la Russie
mais mais durable contre la France du
temps de ses coutourés donc il faut
admettre si vous voulez que nous avons
des opinions publiques dans chaque pays
des situations différentes des problèmes
ethniques dans certains pays qui sont
beaucoup moins sensibles dans d'autres
ou pas de la même façon et que la France
pour des raisons historiques est
associée à ces problèmes est-ce qu'elle
a poussé les peulls est-ce qu'elle était
l'amis des toireg contre les Bambaras et
cetera on a la chance et la richesse
d'une histoire commune très très longue
mais si vous voulez ça va encore prendre
deux générations que cette mémoire
soit
documentée objectivée et
dépassé même l'esclavage a encore une
actualité dans l'imaginaire des des des
des populations en Afrique pourquoi
parce que la loi sur le travail forcé
même un autre nom de l'esclavage la loi
oufouet de boign elle est dans
l'Assemblée nationale de 1946 c'est
récent il y a encore des survivants du
travail forcé donc vous
voyez on a des situations différentes
dans chaque pays avec des histoires avec
la France qui sont passionnantes qui
expliquent pourquoi la diaspora malienne
et la plus grande diaspora subsaharienne
dans ce pays qui participe aux élections
de montreil je ne sais pas on n pas
écouté de de représentants d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts mais si vous
voulez il s'impatiente bon alors parfait
alors à monreil vous devez beaucoup à la
communauté malienne si vous voulez voyez
cette richesse d'échange c'est aussi une
mémoire incroyablement complexe on a va
mettre encore deux générations à
dissiper les
imaginations de défiance merci merci je
renonce à tout
euh pour le groupe des écologistes et
apparentés monsieur tacher ça ça ça
tombait bien puisqueil semblait y avoir
une attente de Monsieur zinzou non merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président pour
cette invitation monsieur beaucoup merci
beaucoup Monsieur le Premier Ministre
d'être avec nous ce matin il y aurait
plein de choses dont on pourrait
discuter vous avez raison de dire qu'il
ne faut pas noircir le tableau sur les
relations entre la France et l'Afrique
il faut peut-être pas l'enjoliver
complètement non plus et nuancer un tout
petit peu euh malheureusement et vous
venez de le reconnaître vous-même dans
un certain nombre des pays du Sahel où
il y a eu je dis bien malheureusement
hein des des des des coups d'états
récemment il semble avoir quand même un
certain soutien de la population c'est
le cas pour le Mali et et peut-être un
peu plus que ce que ce que vous disiez
sur sur dans d'autres pays aussi il y a
aussi des attitudes qui sont peu
comprises de la France parfois certains
encouragements à à à certains présidents
ou candidats en campagne ou certains
silence au contraire sur d'autres pays
je pense au Sénégal mais c'est pas
là-dessus que je voulais vous interroger
je voulais vous interroger sur votre
mission auprès de l'énergie vous vous en
doutez en tant qu'écologiste euh nous
sommes opposés au projet écop C léoduc
de 1500 km qui symbolise finalement le
fait que au moment où à la COP 28 on
parle de sortir des énergies fossiles
malheureusement les les géants
économiques français font un choix
radicalement inverse une commission
d'enquête a d'ailleurs été ouverte au
Sénat par le groupe écologiste par mon
collègue Yannick jado sur cette question
peut-être que vous aurez à aller
échanger avec eux moi je voudrais
revenir sur l'aspect précisément de
votre mission qui est celui de
l'évaluation foncière et des
accquisations des acquisitions foncières
de Total en Ouganda effectivement nous
avons près de plus 118000 personnes je
crois qui ont été expropriées de leur
terr avec de nombreuses violations qui
ont été en tout cas mises en avant il
faudra que la justice tranche par un
certain nombre d'ONG françaises mais
aussi ougandais hein je pense à à à à
l'Institut research ta ou à Friday for
for for future ouanda parce que les
compensations données financières
données par Total à ses familles
semblent très sous-évalué parce que les
familles qui finalement aussi ont refusé
de rentrer dans le processus
d'expropriation se sont trouvé traduites
devant la justice ougandaise il y a
aussi des questions de biodiversité
importantes que que que pose le projet
tilenga qui passe dans le parc national
de mer merchant in FS excusez-moi
anglais qui est mauvais on a les les les
les champansés les éléphants tous ces
animaux et qui forment une biodiversité
incroyable dans cette zone qui sont en
train de de fuir donc vous voyez ce
projet au-delà même des conséquen qu'il
aura sur le climat pose des tas de
questions sur finalement les
conséquences qu'il a sur le vivant la
biodiversité et surtout ces 120000
ougandais exproprié j'aimerais savoir ce
que vous pouvez nous dire là-dessus ce
matin merci monsieur le député monsieur
zinzou
oui merci monsieur le député alors ça n
pas un rapport très direct avec le
rapport d'information de votre de votre
commission euh ça en aurait eu
d'ailleurs plus si comme nous disions
tout à l'heure les entreprises
françaises
avait été décrite dans la relation entre
l'Afrique et la France c'est une mission
indépendante qui est le pendant d'une
mission que Total Energie avait confié à
Monsieur Jean-Christophe Ruffin sur le
Mozambique le le groupe groupe Total
Energie a souhaité qu'il y ait un
diagnostic indépendant indépendamment
donc de ce qui remonte de l'intérieur de
la de la société indépendamment de ce
qui est exprimé par les les autorités
publiques de l'ouanda et de la Tanzanie
sur le respect des des droits humains et
des règles de droit sous toutes les
formes et donc l'idée c'est de parler à
l'ensemble je viens d'ailleurs que je
dois vous remercier que vous proposie de
de de parler et avec vous-même et avec
Monsieur
jado au titre de la commission qui été
créé au Sénat sur ce sujet c'est tout à
fait la mission c'est de regarder toutes
les parties prenantes en Ouganda en
Tanzanie donc j'iraai d'ici une semaine
en Ouganda pays que je connais en
Tanzanie où j'étais récemment parler
avec les autorités publiques les
autorités locales y compris
traditionnelles parce que ce sont des
villages qui sont affectés ce sont des
des districts des provinces et les
collectivités locales ont des attentes
considérables vous êtes sensible au fait
que dans beaucoup de pays les
collectivités où il y a des personnes
affectées
expropriées d'où vient la production
sont parfois parmi les dernières à
partager les royalty les bénéfices les
retombées fiscales et les retrombées
d'emploi et cetera donc les
collectivités locales c'est vraiment
important les élus et donc aussi
longtemps qu'il faudra bon ça dure 3
mois mais on va être à la disposition y
compris des ONG locales des ONG
généralistes
euh européenne ou les fondations comme
la Fondation européenne pour le
climat aussi bien que les les ONG
spécialisé qui travaillent sur la
biodiversité sur l'accès à l'eau potable
sur les ressources aliotiques et cetera
bon donc c'est des pays que je connais
c'est des en partie des des des des
institutions que je connais mais enfin
voilà on va on va grosso modo essayer de
parler à tous la seule valeur de ce
rapport sera forcément un peu exposer
quels que soient les les
conséquences c'est totalement d'être je
crois que vous avez reçu Monsieur
Patrick pouyané monsieur le
présidentépend tot lui voilà mais l'idée
c'est de faire un
rapport honnête et indépendant reflétant
en tout cas tous les tous les points de
vue qui sont en effet très très
controversés et de faire des des des des
recommandations additionnel et on m'a
demandé ça en tant que je suis censé
être de
professionéconomiste du développement si
vous voulez et donc là-dessus avec pas
mal d'économistes on a une réflexion il
n'est plus possible pour les industrie
extractive quelle qu'elle soit de
continuer de faire des investissements
qui d'un point de vue capitalistique
sont considérables avec un effet emploi
très faible il y a pas plus capitaliste
que de faire du pétrole et de fabriquer
des pipelines vous dépensez 12 milliards
d'euros sur
tilangacop et vous allez créer infin
moins de 2000 emplois qualifiés dans la
durée point avec 12 milliards
d'investissements dans les domaines de
l'agriculture de la forêt de la
biodiversité du tourisme de la pêchef
tout ce qui pourrait être fait dans
cette région mais avec 12 milliards vous
faites pas 2000 emplois faites 200000
emplois voilà par conséquent il y a
quelque chose qui est complètement
nouveau et sur lequel moi je crois il
faut qu'on insiste énormément parce que
c'est une vraie attente des pays quand
on fait des des des investissements
extraordinairement intensif en capital
il faut faire à côté sinon c'est
inacceptable par les populations c'est
inacceptable des investissement à impact
et je crois que ça commence à être
compris
et que il est temps de passer à l'acte
si vous voulez et donc on ne peut pas
dans des provinces très pauvres sinon on
arrive à des situations nigérianes où
les populations où on produit le pétrole
finissent par devoir le voler dans les
pipelines s'ils veulent avoir des
retombées économiques c'est c'est
l'impact par le
crime c'est c'est intolérable c'est
insupportable combien de de de pays sont
affectés de ça de la Tunisie à à
à notre au
nigériacité beaucoup en Asie partout ça
ne peut pas durer en tout cas en Afrique
c'est un élément essentiel de de la
justice voilà les deux points du rapport
être un pur miroir de ce que les gens
pensent et des faits et d'autre part
essayer de faire qu'il y ait des projets
additionnels parce que c'est ça le
modèle économique soutenable non mais
nous ser sans doute amenés à à vous
consulter à nouveau quand vous quand
vous aurez produit votre rapport parce
que c'est ce sont des sujets qui sont
absolument passionnants et je pense que
cette commission sera tout à fait
intéressé de vous questionner sur vos
conclusions le maintenant la la parole
est à pour
la la Gauche démocrate et républicaine
madame
rbelot monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur
zzou
c'est-à-dire que vous ayez une belle
année une bonne année nouvelle alors
monsieur zinzou je vous remercie pour
votre intervention et en particulier sur
votre éclairage sur la perception
biaisée en France et par les Français du
rejet français en Afrique étant moi-même
député polynésienne indépendantiste je
suis confronté à cette fausse perception
hexagonale je rappelle que le 17 mai
2013 la Polynésie française a été
inscrite sur la liste onusienne des pays
non autonomes à
décoloniser je ferme la parenthèse alors
au nom de mon groupe je souhaitais
parler de changement climatique de
biodiversité et d'autonomie alimentaire
mais mes collègues vous ont déjà
interrogé sur ces sujets voici donc la
question qui me tenait à cœur la
question d'une minute que j'avais
préparé en fin de en fin de commission
dans votre livre la France et l'Afrique
publié en 2020 vous écrivez grâce au
partage de la langue au soutien des
artistes à la sauvegarde du patrimoine
ou à la restitution des œuvres d'art on
reconstruit du respect on rend mémoire
on exauce l'histoire c'est la jeunesse
du continent qui le demande c'est elle
qui veut pouvoir retrouver l'histoire
précoloniale celle des grands empires du
fait de votre travail au sein de la
Société des Amis du musé Branly et de
votre fondation culturelle avez-vous
déjà été confronté à la question d'une
restitution d'objets culturels ou de
restes
humains que pensez-vous du texte de loi
récemment adopté par le Parlement
français à ce sujet au niveau des restes
humains pourauriez-vous ajouter ou
améliorer à cette loi cadre et
qu'attendez-vous du texte à venir sur
les restitutions d'objets culturels je
vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
député Monsieur
zinzouirconscription
polinés Merci beaucoup madame madame la
députée
euh d'abord je voudrais dire que
les relations avec les départements et
territoirees d'autres m c'est quelque
chose qui est de plus en plus sensible
dans les pays
africains alors évidemment peut-être
plus qu'avec la Polynésie à ce jour avec
les territoires département d'outr mer
de l'océan Indien et des Caraïbes
évidemment c'est de plus en plus
important parce que ça fait partie de
cette espèce de mémoire commune
collective et de cette situation
particulière où les afhrodescendants les
polyisiens les population de de la
réunion de Mayotte et cetera ont des
origines très diverses des histoires
très
diverse il y avait pas de peuple
autochtone à la
Réunion tout le monde tout le monde est
halogène à la
Réunion voilà en Polynésie c'est très
différent donc on a des histoires très
différentes mais on a quand même des
solidarités
fondamental et qui sont de plus en plus
vivantes je trouve d'ailleurs que le
passé l'histoire c'est pour ça qu'on
écrivait ce qu'on écrivait sur c'est
très très important de de de de
retrouver des des racine historique le
président Hollande m'avait fait
l'honneur de me demander de préfigurer
la Fondation nationale
pour la mémoire et l'histoire de
l'esclavage qui a été créé
euh en 2000 2017 18 qui est présidé par
Jean-Marc herud bon parce que c'est ce
sont les mêmes causes en fait et ça très
grand très grand rapport la façon dont
l'outremè français est est géré
politiquement par la France ça a
beaucoup d'écho en fait en Afrique et
j'imagine que le sentiment de rejet de
la France par ces pays du Global sou que
sont les pays africains ça a aussi un
écho sur les populations des départ les
territoires d'autre mer donc merci parce
que je pense c'est un lien très fort les
restes humains vous savez c'est une idée
de Jacques Chirac pour pouvoir
contourner
l'inaliabilité
des dans les collections français de ce
qui est venu des des pays d'Afrique et
donc on a pu distinguer les artefacts
des restes humains et je crois qu'on va
continuer c'est comme ça que Lucy a été
rendu à l'éth éthopie parce que s'il y a
eu une constance entre le président
mitteran qui a rendu sous forme de prêt
à long terme parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
les aliéner les manuscrits sacrés de la
Corée puis Jacques Chirac qui a fait
avancer sur les restes humains il y
avait on butait sur cette impossibilité
de sortir des collections françaises
alors qu'on peut sortir des collections
publique américaine allemande et cetera
mais c'est pas le cas en France et et
donc et le président mitteran et le
président Chirac ont trouvé C ces moyens
d'aller plus loin la représent
représentation nationale a voté à
l'unanimité pour l'Assemblée sur le
Sénégal et le Bénin mais il faudra une
loi ad hoc pour chaque restitution c'est
pas possible il y aura donc une loi
cadre madame RA abdoumek avait
pratiquement terminé le programme qui
s'appuie vous le savez sur un rapport au
chef de l'État par Monsieur FN madame
Benedict savois professeur au Collège de
France et à l'Université de muniich et
donc si vous voulez je crois que le
travail est fait va bientôt venir en
commission ce que je
connais mon ami madame la ministre de la
Culture c'est qu'elle va beckon comme
elle
dirait
enfin projeter projeter C cette loi
cadre qui permettrait d'avoir une une
solution générique et personnellement
moi j'en attends j'en attends beaucoup
parce que je crois que encore une fois
l'immatériel est très important dans la
relation franco-africaine et dans la
relation avec les pays de d'outr les
territoires et départements d'outremè
monsieur
casarerou pourquoi il est un
extraordinaire président du musée
Jacques Chirac vous savez je suis très
fier parce que comme je suis membre du
conseil d'administration j'avais propos
propé qu'on fit une exception qu'on a
faite de donner au président Chirac son
nom au musée du kebrand de son vivant
tradition étant qu'on le fasse
postmortem et et et on l'a fait de son
vivant si vous voulez monsieur
casazarerou c'est aussi l'homme qui a
fait
le le grand inventaire de
l'arcanac en main mondiale dans toutes
les collections du monde et c'est le
créateur du centre culturel chibaou il
est parfaitement à sa place dans ce
musée des Arts non occidentaux qui est
le deuxième plus grand musée
anthropologique du monde si vous voulez
pour
moi c'est un atout de la France
considérable et j'espère que la
représentation nationale donnera
effectivement les moyens législatifs
qu'on puisse continuer dans cette dans
cette voie vous pouvez pas imaginer
comme ça la jeunesse africaine en est
reconnaissante avec le sentiment qu'elle
y avait
droit oui c'est deux choses différentes
ce ce pldoyer sera certainement et
certainement entendu par chacun d'entre
nous le dernier orateur au
titre au titre des groupes et au titre
des non inscrits et Monsieur
dupontignan Merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
nous avoir autant
montrer que l'Afrique était
pluriel de nous avoir aussi et on n'en
doutait pas prouver que l'Afrique sera
un géant du 21e siècle et que selon la
manière dont elle se développera
dépendra à la fois le bonheur des
Africains et l'équilibre du monde et
l'équilibre de l'Europe voilà pourquoi
nos
liens sont si
essentiel je voudrais revenir sur
quelques points
précis complémentair
de ce que vous avez dit d'abord le
premier la transition démographique vous
nous avez dit qu'elle été très rapide
dans certains pays je voudrais
concentrer sur l'affaire du Sahel qui
est la quand même la grande zone de
faiblesse du continent africain suite à
l'intervention d'ailleurs malheureuse en
Libye et sur votre vision des moyens
concrets
d'améliorer de résoudre enfin de de
créer cette transition démographique
sujet àout en mais qui n'est pas tabou
pour les dirigeants de cette zone
puisque quantité de chefs d'État chef de
gouvernement en ont parlé c'est un
problème majeur notamment le statut des
femmes et la manière dont cette période
tragique on peut faire avancer la
transition démographique de cette zone
la deuxième
question concerne le rapport entre
l'aide au développement et les
ressources naturelles de l'Afrique il a
l'IDE très bien on pourrait dire
beaucoup d'ailleurs sur lafd c'est un de
mes combats pour que lafd soit le BR
opérationnel d'une volonté politique et
ne soit pas en apesanteur mais au-delà
de cela la juste rétribution du des
matières premières comment faire en
sorte pour que la fluctuation des
matières premières je pense au cacao je
pense à toutes ces richesses qui sont
financiarisés aujourd'hui comment faire
en sorte pour que l'agriculture
africaine puisse bénéficier d'une sorte
de sécurité minimum de prix qui
permettent l'investiss
l'emploi éviter l'exode trop massif dans
des villes qui ne sont plus gérées avec
des problèmes de pauvreté bref comment
vous
appréhendez l'idée d'organiser mieux la
gestion des matières premières et puis
dernière question sur la hausse des taux
d'intérêt qui prend un revers beaucoup
de pays qui ont une dette importante
comment on peut faire pour éviter au
moment où il y a des investissements
colossaux à
effectués en matière première et là je
suis en total désaccord avec ce qui a
été dit sur le projet pétrolier parce
que je pense que l'Afrique a le droit de
se développer d'avoir des ressources
mais où vous avez totalement raison
comment on fait pour qu'il y ait des
emplois et comment on dessert les taux
des taux d'intérêt qui est absolument
dramatique en ce moment je vous remercie
je vous remercie c'est Monsieur si vous
voulez répondre merci oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le député pour ces questions
qui sont à la fois euh tout à fait
pertinentes et et et assez rarement posé
d'ailleurs donc je vous remercie
doublement maintenant monsieur le
président vous remarquerez que le
supplice de vos invités c'est que non
seulement les questions sont pertinentes
et donc demandent de longues réponses
mais elles sont souvent quand même
multiplesent et sur des sujets qui sont
pas très petits
merci monsieur le
Président vous jetons pas la pierre n ne
vous jetons pas la pierre de répondre
longuement au contraire nous en sommes
comblés mais le temps le temps n'est pas
galantomme monsieur put vous avez rendu
service à cette commission de permettre
de parler des
femmes les femmes sont
essentiel dans la compréhension de la
croissance de l'Afrique c'est
probablement les meilleurs gestionnaires
des patrimoines des ménages c'est
probablement le premier échelon de de
l'éducation de la formation alors dans
notre
pays matriarcal où en plus ce sont les
grandes fortunes les fameux Mama Mama
Benz qui sont les grandes commerçantes
de nos de nos grands marchés si vous
voulez on n pas de difficultés à assurer
la parité sur le plan politique ou autre
parce que elles ont un rôle considérable
c'est un peu différent dans les pays de
tradition patriarcal évidemment et
notamment peut-être le Sahel est plus
patriarcal que l'Afrique
côtière enfin c'est très important parce
que c'est de l'autonomie des femmes de
leur capacité d'accéder à la possession
de la terre qui est encore minoritaire
en Afrique euh qui est de leur capacité
d'accéder à l'emploi vous voyez on a un
problème terrible et pour la démographie
et pour le développement au au sud de
mon pays mais ce serait pareil pour la
Côte d'Ivoire le ganard et cetera on a
dans la capitale 95 % de scolarisation
donc toutes les filles sont scolarisées
au nord on a à peu près 30 % de
scolarisation et à ce moment-là presque
aucune fille n'est scolarisée parce
qu'on donne la la priorité aux enfants
les conséquences démographiques sont
considérables parce que l'autonomie des
femmes le niveau d'éducation la capacité
d'avoir des des des grossesses suivies
donc de réduire la mortalité en couche
infantile et cetera tout cela si vous
voulez c'est corrélé euh et donc la la
transition la rapidité de la transition
démographique je vous dis elle est
extraordinaire rapide dans les pays du
maghreèb mais mais pas dans le Sahel
maghrébain d'ailleurs mais mais mais
dans le côtier pourquoi parce que les
progrès de la santé de l'éducation de
l'autonomie des femmes les lois
tunisiennes de bourgiba c'est
fondamental pour l'expliquer donc c'est
pas qu'une question de planning familial
c'est vraiment une question du rôle
qu'on donne aux femmes et de l'accès au
bien commun au service public et donc
vous avez tout à fait raison là-dessus
et et et c'est devenu une une priorité
avec une autre priorité
qui est de lutter contre les
carences parce que l'extrême pauvreté
c'est la différence avec la pauvreté
c'est c'est c'est le niveau de pauvreté
ou même aux générations suivantes vous
n'allez pas sortir de la pauvreté quelle
que soit la croissance du pays parce que
vous avez accumulé des carences et ça ça
se joue dans les 1000 jours de la
grossesse de la mer allaitante et du
nourriçon jusqu'à 2 ans et maintenant il
y a quelques pays d'ailleurs il se
trouve que le mien veut en être le le
leader pour tout le continent où on a
tout un travail sur la sécurité
alimentaire les les contenus vitaminique
protéiqu et cetera de des 1000 jours
clés de façon à faire recurer reculer
les les carences donc si vous voulez sur
la transition c'est pour ça qu'il y a
autant d'inégalité dans la rapidité de
transition démographique point de vue
démographique le Maghreb est devenu
européen c'est incroyable mais Abidjan
est devenu européen Cotonou est devenu
européen mais pas niam mais pas
wagadougou donc il y a des inégalités
mais qui joue énormément sur ce
paramètre que vous avez évoqué sur
d'ailleurs du point de vue d'ailleurs
financier on est en train de mettre en
place le plus possible de fonds
d'investissement pour accompagner les
femmes en fait parce que on a une rareté
incroyable du capital surtout pour les
femmes or ce sont parmi les plus
créatrices on est estime que c'est
probablement le continent où il y a le
plus de femmes entrepreneuses et
entreprenantes sur l'aide si vous voulez
et la juste rémunération des des des
produits là
aussi la vision qu'on avait encore
d'ailleurs j'avais travailléve Bruno
Lemer à l'époque sous la en 2011
présidence française du G20 et le
président Sarkozy voulait qu'on qu'on
travaille sur des mécanismes de garantie
de prix de matières premières notamment
agricole on n'a pas le luxe de faire
comme l'Union européenne si vous voulez
de fixer des prix et de
fixer et de faire des transfert
monétaire très important de façon à à la
fois en fond
structurel permettre un développement et
et surtout ce que faisait le foga
c'est-à-dire d'avoir une aide au
produit massive en fait qui fait que moi
j'ai une maison dans l'Orne en dehors de
ma maison au Bénin et mes voisins
gagnent moitié leur vie sur les prix des
produits prix de marché et moitié sur
les transferts l'aide maintenant au
producteur mais enfin peut être au
produit au producteur on n' pas les
moyens budgétaires de faire quelque
chose qui ressemble malheureusement à ça
en revanche ce qui est en train de se
faire c'est
l'industrialisation de nos matières
premières agricoles dès lors que vous
avez un ofter comme on dit de nos jours
vous avez un acheteur final qui va
transformer votre produit votre manioc
votre maïs votre lait et cetera vous un
en amont il y a un intérêt de
l'industriel qui va décupler la valeur
du produit à investir lui-même en amont
pour donner plus de semence plus
d'engrais plus de mécanisation donc ça
transfère des ressources pour assurer
des contrats de long terme et donc ça
élève les rendement de façon très
importante et donc vous voyez cela qui
commence c'est les tout début
dans laquelle la juste rétribution ça
n'est pas ça peut pas être un mécanisme
de transfert budgétaire faut être à un
niveau de développement et de de
ressources de finances publi très
supérieure c'est à la portée de deux ou
trois pays si vous voulez sur le
continent mais c'est la valorisation
avale qui est tellement importante et si
les entreprises françaises sont
tellement dominantes en matière agro
alimentaire si vous voulez sont
tellement importantes je pense à
laactalis la première à Danon la 2è à et
cetera et cetera les grandes
coopératives par exemple qui sont
majeurs les grands é protéagineux et
cetera mais mais il y a un boulevard
pour l'industrie française et j'auraai à
ce moment-là ce rôle de rétribuer
infiniment mieux l'amont sans qu'on rêve
que ce soit par des transferts de fonds
public c'est ça la pour l'instant le
chemin sur auquel je crois sur les taux
d'intérêt vous avez tout àit fait raison
les marchés financiers sont fermés à
l'Afrique sauf peut-être pour la finance
verte pourquoi parce que ils sont
devenus exorbitant en prix et donc
l'actualité de l'Afrique 2024- 2025 ça
va être un terrible crédit crunch parce
que il faut pouvoir rembourser les
eurobondes des années précédentes en en
se réendettant or on peut plus se
réendetter sur les marchés et ça ça va
être un problème donc l'Afrique intérêt
vital à la baisse très rapide des taux
d'intérêt les pays de la zone franc
puisqu tout à l'heure il y avait une
question sur le CFA ont l'immense
avantage d'avoir les taux d'intérêt les
plus bas du du continent et la stabilité
des monnaies les plus fortes la raison
pour laquelle dans mon pays notre notre
inflation est à 3
% alors que dans le pays très voisin du
Ghana est à 45 % pour l'année 2023 et
dans l'autre pays avec lequel on a 700
km de frontière elle est à 30 % c'est le
Nigéria c'est que nous avons une monnaie
stable qui fait son boulot de monnaie et
que nous avons l'inflation la plus basse
et et du coup les taux d'intérêt les
plus bas mais c'est vrai que c'est une
exception bon le Maroc est un peu dans
cette situation parce qu'il esté
relativement stable jjibouti et cetera
il y a il y a quelques exceptions pour
l'instant c'est une exception les taux
d'intérêt nous martyrisent plus que tous
les autres parce que nous avons une
prime de risque au-dessus de tous les
autres et par ailleurs nous avons
beaucoup moins de risqu que la
perception des risques donc si vous
voulez vous mettez le doigt là sur
quelque chose qui ne va pas nous
handicaper sur une génération mais qui
va nous étrangler en 2004 en 2024 en
2025 bien les les je vous remercie
c'était c'était passionnant notamment
cette dernière cette dernière partie de
la réponse je pouvais absolument pas me
permettre de faire la moindre remarque
et j'en étais fort
mari maintenant j'ai les les les
parlementaires veulent s'exprimer il est
hors de question de faire comme on fait
d'habitude c'est-à-dire une minute par
personne et la réponse de de de l'invité
je suis obligé de faire un tir
groupé en deux en deux je vais faire
deux tirs groupés pour que chacun se
souvienne donc d'abord c'est 4 et tr
d'abord
monsieur
une minute ensuite je demanderai à
Stéphanie Galzi et à Julien Laferrière
chacun une minute et le monsieur zinzou
répondra à ces troisl et ensuite on aura
les derniers intervenant voilà fréri
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur zinzou pour ces précisions très
très intéressant je voulais évoquer moi
le fait bon malgré des engagements
militaires qui s'accentuent en Afrique
la France a opté donc pour une stratégie
économique forte sur le continent vous
l'avez évoqué et je vrais prendre
l'exemple du du Nigéria qui est
particulièrement parlant avec des
échanges économiques entre nos deux
nations qui ont doublé depuis 10 ans
faisant ainsi du Nigéria le premier
partenaire commercial de la France en
Afrique subsaharienne et le 4e derrière
le Maroc l'Algérie la Tunisie euh il y a
plus de 10000 travailleurs français le
siège de près d'une centaine
d'entreprises autrement dit les
relations entretenues et renforcées avec
le Nigéria sont un modèle de réussite et
la présence économique française sur le
territoire sans faire obstacle aux
influences russes et chinoises et donc
selon vous euh cette stratégie
économique qui contrebalance l'idée d'un
recul de la France sur le continent
africain peut-elle se calquer sur
d'autres pays d'Afrique et si oui
lesquels je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président la
France est parfois accusée de
néocolonialisme économique et monétaire
à travers le Fran CFA qui fait l'objet
de critique depuis sa création c'est ces
critiques sont devenus l'un des
principaux sujets de contestation dirigé
contre la France en Afrique de l'Ouest
et cela souvent à tort la nonstratégie
en matière de politique africaine de la
France démontre la défaillance de notre
pays envers un continent que nous avons
pourtant aidé à se développer au cours
de son histoire ceci risque d'être fort
préjudiciable pour notre pays et
d'entraîner une perte de confiance
économique pour les entreprises
françaises en Afrique un débat est
actuellement en cours sur un changement
de monnaie et pour certains cela
entraînera une nouvelle perte
d'influence pouvez-vous nous donner
votre position sur ce débat je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame
monsieur Julien Laferrière merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur zou
parce que qu'on soit d'accord avec vous
ou pas je pense qu'on a aujourd'hui
entendu beaucoup de choses sur l'Afrique
qu'on avait encore jamais entendu
auparavant donc merci beaucoup j'ai
premièrement j'étais un peu surpris de
votre réponse à mon collègue taché sur
ECOP parce que je trouve que vous avez
dit presque le contraire de ce que vous
avez dit dans vos propos préliminaires
donc peut-être vous pourrez préciser un
peu vous étiez vous disiez au fond que
il y avait des ONG étrangères qui qui
qui critiquaient le projet et que tous
les Ougandais le soutenaient et puis
vous avez été un peu plus nuancé lorsque
vous avez répondu à Monsieur tacher euh
est-ce que vous vous dites qu'on
surestime le effectivement le déclin de
la France et de l'image de la France en
en Afrique alors c'est vrai que les les
les coups d'État les machines à troll
les manif onont pas besoin d'avoir le
soutien majoritaire des des populations
moi-même qui é qui suis allé une
quinzaine de fois dans votre P au Bénin
ou au Burkina Faso j'y suis retourné
j'étais pas allé pendant 10 ans je suis
retourné tout récemment c'est vrai qu'on
peut toujours manger un poulet grillé
dans un Maqui ou aller boire un coup le
soir on est aussi bien accueilli mais
est-ce que quand même vous sous-estimez
pas un peu notamment l'influence de la
Russie vous dites influence de la
réussie c'est quand même Wagner qui qui
gouverne la Centrafrique enfin ou ou pas
loin et enfin j'ai juste une dernière
question est-ce qu'il faut normaliser
nos relations avec la jeinte nigérienne
ou pas c'est juste une question merci
voilà c'est c'est maintenant il y a
plusieurs questions mais il y a quand
même plusieurs questionneurs aussi c'est
là où j'ai progressé merci monsieur le
député merci de votre question sur
l'engagement dans un certain nombre de
pays parce que ça me permet de rappeler
quelque chose dont je pense que le
rapport aurait pu peut-être l'écrire en
toutes lettres le précarré africain
francophone est une
illusion française
je crains même que ce soit de l'UCE
française parce que la relation entre
l'Afrique et la France repose très
faiblement sur les pays francophones
d'Afrique subsaharienne donc h Magreb
Magreb c'est
particulier l'Algérie enh dealgérie pard
la Tunisie et le Maroc font plus de
commerce avec les pays de l'Union
européenne en proportion de leurs
échanges qu'une partie des pays de
l'Union européenne entre eux on ne peut
pas faire plus européen que la Tunisie
et le Maroc d'un point de vue du
commerce extérieur donc la part de
marché française qui est un peu de moins
de 3 %
mondialement atteint 15 % en Maghreb le
Maghreb c'est très particulier c'est des
pays neighboring de de l'Union
européenne mais l'Afrique subsaharienne
qui est votre sujet n'est pas du tout du
tout du point de vue économique le
partenaire africain de la
France les échanges avec le Nigéria
merci d'avoir
développé sont les plus importants
suivis de l'Afrique du Sud et de
l'Égypte c'est-à-dire les trois pays les
plus
importants en terme de PIB du continent
et qui est-ce qui est en train de monter
à toute vitesse l'Angola ça va être la
Namibie assez vite vous disiez quel pays
B par nature les pays de l'OCA
c'estàdire Kenya Tanzanie
Ouganda Rwanda et Burundi qui est avec
notre région à nous là de l'union
économique monétaire
ouestaricaine c'est les moteurs de
croissance c'est pas le Mozambique et le
Mozambique pardon va avoir également ce
rôle c'estàdire des pays non
francophones alors il faut le ver très
vite c'est pour ça que il faut toujours
questionner les chiffres quand vous
voyez un chiffre sur l'Afrique mesdames
messieurs les députés et regardez sa
construction il y a beaucoup plus de
francophones au Nigéria qu'au Bénin pour
une raison très simple c'est qu'on
enseigne le français de le secondaire et
qu' a 220 millions il y a 220 millions
d'habitants et qu'il y a 80 millions de
de d'écoliers et nous toute notre
population c'est 12 millions vous
imaginez bien que le Nigéria est un pays
Franco cophone beaucoup plus important
et d'ailleurs le président de la
République quand il est allé à au
Nigéria pour la dernière fois il a
inauguré la plus grande alliance
Française du monde construite par des
milliardaires nigériens en hommage à la
France parce que il y a des listes
d'attentes incroyables aussi bien en
Alliance française qu'en lycée
français on est en arrêt sur
image juste une petite
anecdote pendant la campagne
présidentielle au Bénin on me dit
journaliste me dit dans la télévision on
vous a envoyé comme gouverneur des
colonies moi j'ai l'habitude donc ça
m'amuse et donc je leur réponds écoutez
en
France il me semble que le parti des
gens qui veulent recoloniser l'Afrique
est quand même
discret et puis alors j'ajoute un truc
là que j'apis que quand on est un
politicien amateur enfin on sait pas du
tout manié le second degré et je leur
dit mais vous êtes bien sûr par ailleurs
que si la France voulait recoloniser
quelqu'un ça serait le Bénin alors là je
me suis fait insulter sur le thème non
seulement c'est le gouverneur des
colonie qu'on nous a envoyé mais en plus
il considère qu'on n'est pas digne
d'être recolonisé si vous voulez bon
jeis faire très attention à ce genre de
ce genre de chose ne restons pas en
arrêt sur image vous savez ce que ça
représente le le le commerce extérieur
avec la zone
franc central donc le fr CFA donc
occidental plus les Comores
0,6 % du commerce extérieur français à
qui vend-on des rafales à l'Égypte à qui
vend-t-on des porte hélicoptère amphibie
à l'Égypte à qui on va livrer des
centrales nucléaires demain avec qui on
établit on crée des flotes de glace
l'Afrique du Sud l'Égypte pas le Bénin
pas la Côte d'Ivoire pas le Gabon c'est
incroyable comme la France croit qu'il y
a encore un
précarré ce Pr carré pour les intérêts
français n'existe pas c'est une fiction
c'est une fiction et ça je ne sais pas
comment on peut faire parce que quand je
dis ça personne me croit c'est tellement
fort et c'est un péché Dubris que de
penser côté français on nous rejette le
problème c'est pas le rejet français ça
pourrait gagner ce qui pourrait gagner
c'est l'indifférence et pas le rejet si
vous voulez merci d'avoir parler des
maquis béninois où vous êtes bien
accueilliis pour manger du on est à 528
j'ai encore une une série de questions
donc alors donc sur le CFA excusez-moi
je j'y ai fait j'y ai fait un peu
allusion dans la les circonstances
actuel d'inflation de taux d'intérêt
très élevé de chaos pour les pays
émergents sur les marchés financiers le
CFA qui ne fait l'objet d'aucun double
change fuite devant la monnaie et est un
atout important madame la députée vous
avez demandé s'il y avait une révision
monétaire en cours et vous avez dit
quelque chose qui m'a amusé que ce
serait probablement demain le fait que
la zone franc éclate elle va bien bien
bouger la la jaune franc vous avez dit
ça sera encore une preuve plus grande du
déclin français alors je vous rappelle
les propos de Madame Marine Le Pen Anne
jamena à côté de feu Idriss Deb HNO et
la critique par Madame Marine Le Pen de
l'existence du francfa et ça m'a
beaucoup frappé parce qu'elle a employé
une
métaphore je suis pas sûr que j'approuve
cette métaphore en disant pour la
monnaie c'est comme pour la virginité on
n'est pas à
demiierge et par conséquent c'est pareil
pour la monnaie on ne partage pas sa
souveraineté monétaire le Fran CFA est
une séquelle coloniale je vois madame
que vous attendez que ça devienne vrai
que nous soyons encore rejetés de
quelque
chose à travers la monnaie que ça soit
une preuve du rejet français mais alors
il faudra que les historiens rappellent
que c étit un appel je crois que c'est
la personnalité politique française la
plus importante qui est fait une
critique en territoire africain
de l'existence du Fran CFA aujourd'hui
vous semblez trouver que c'est
une un échec à venir mais il faut pas
faire la publicité de l'échec et
l'apologie de de de promess à venir si
je comprends surcope ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure
c'est la France
s'autoflagè volontiers et effectivement
sur total énergie en réalité
quantitativement devant les tribunaux
de toutes les façons possibles et
imaginables ce sont des ONG des
fondations européennes et notamment
françaises qui sont les plus actives en
revanche les attentes de population je
ne dis pas du tout qu'il n'y a pas des
ONG des associations de l'Ouganda de la
Tanzanie du Mozambique demain et je vous
renvoie à cet égard au au rapport de
Jean-Christophe Ruffin sur le Mozambique
il y a évidemment des
lo
mais
quantitativement c'est beaucoup plus
marginal que les attente local c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire une question
de
proportion dans mon introduction je
voulais juste indiquer que il y a un
masochisme
français sur sur
l'Afrique vous avez dit monsieur le
député que
Wagner gérait les pays africains
pasoup temps oui
alors et vous avez pris l'exemple de la
Centrafrique l'ordre public en
centraafrique est assuré et là encore ne
restons pas en arrêt sur image mais
estil assuré par les troupes
rwandaises je ne comprends pas en dehors
de la fixation sur Wagner Wagner est en
position de garde
prétorienne du pouvoir politique d'
bangi ce qui fait qu'il reste un peu
d'ordre public en centra-afrique
d'ailleurs un peu de plus en plus c'est
la présence des troupes rwandaises vous
feriez
également référence pourriez faire
référence au Mozambique qui avait fait
appel à Wagner contre les shebab
notamment dans la rison du Cabo Delgado
où il y a lesis et total énergie sur les
plus grandes réserves de gaz naturel de
l'océan Indien Wagner a échoué Wagner a
été congédié ce sont les forces les
forces rwandaises en fait qui ont
rétabli la paix au nord du
Mozambique vous ne pouvez pas faire
cette fixation sur
Wagner comment voulez-vous que Wagner en
terme d'équipement en terme de
commandement et ça n'it pas été affecté
par le fait que tout l'équipement russe
va en Ukraine et que le commandement a
disparu d'un coup par un malheureux
accident comment pouvoir comment peut-on
rester à ce point figé sur Wagner au
Mali c'est l'armée malienne qui a
reconquis c'est c'est c'est l'armée
malienne certes avec quelques hommes de
Wagner mais c'est l'armée malienne qui a
reconquis
Kidal et ça d'ailleurs pour la France
c'est quand même troublant parce que la
France est un peu accusée de ne pas
avoir cherché à libérer Kidal du fait
des toireg mais c'est l'armée malienne
qui l'a fait ça fait partie des peurs
françaises Chine Russie Turquie ce sont
des émotions françaises mais sur le
terrain ce sont des exceptions en
Afrique
Mali centraafrique Soudan au total
probablement 1500 hommes et ils sont
très loin d'accaparer les mines les
mines d'or du Sahel sont
sud-africaines Suisse marocaine
canadienne il y en a pas une Française
et Wagner s'est fait a obtenu deux
concessions voilà bon j'ai quatre j'ai
quatre orateurs encore donc hléonore
carois merci monsieur le Président il y
a 6 mois le président Macron a organisé
un sommet pour le nouveau pacte
financier mondial avec pour ambition de
réformer le système financier
international et provoquer un choc de
financement pour qu'un un pays n'est à
choisir entre la réduction de la
pauvreté et la lutte contre le
changement climatique à travers des
interventions des présidents Rama fosa
Ruto mackyall les pays africains se sont
montrés très favorables à l'agenda de
Paris pour les peuples et la planète ils
sont apparus coordonnés revendiquant un
poids politique accru dans les instances
multilatérales et un rôle beaucoup plus
actif dans une gouvernance mondiale
transformée l'Afrique est au cœur de
notre APD
un/ers sur le continent africain et
s'est concentré sur 19 pays euh 18 sont
en Afrique donc c'est les pays
prioritaires dans ce contexte on en a
déjà parlé mais j'aimerais si vous le
souhaitez revenir dessus j'aimerais
avoir votre regard sur l'évolution de la
coopération française en Afrique doit-on
et surtout peut-on faire évoluer un
système encore très largement basé sur
des subventions vers une relation
d'avantage partenarial êtes-vous
favorable à l'annulation à la
restructuration des dettes souveraines
africaines je vous remercie bien ben en
une minute c'est des questions que
auquel monsieur zinzou aura du mal à
répondre dans le même délai merci Madame
la vice-présidente madame Soudet
merci monsieur le Président outre les
questions sécuritaires l'échec politique
de la présence militaire française au
sel ne doit pas nous faire éluder les
enjeux climatiques environnementaux
sociaux ou économiques qui nous liit au
continent africain pour faire face à ces
défis notre programme fait le choix de
l'intérêt général humain de la
coopération bien loin des logiques
néolibérales de la macronie et de ses
soutiens politiques et financiers des
régimes en pleine dérive autoritaire
exemple le gouvernement talon lorsqu'il
condamne à l'exile ou enferme ses
opposants politiques tels que l'ancienne
ministre re madouou à qui il refuse une
enquête indépendante pourtant recommandé
par l'ONU Monsieur Z dans un contexte où
les peuples aspirent à conquérir
davantage de souveraineté à mettre fin à
des relations asymétriques et se l des
soutiens politiques à géométrie variable
du gouvernement français quel bilan
dressez-vous de la politique française
en Afrique de ces années
macronx comment madame il faut laisser
mon taxi en attente oui merci merci
désoléés non
mais non mais vous êtes punis par
lesffet de vos qualité euh monsieur
buisson oui monsieur le Président je
vais essayer de faire vite donc je vous
remercie pour cette présentation qui
déconstruit l'image anachronique je
dirais même presque en noir et blanc du
néocolonialisme de la nupè je vous
remercie donc pour cette présentation et
euh je suis corapporteur d'une mission
d'information sur les ressources
naturelles stratégiques et les terres
rares et je souhaiterais aborder avec
vous une question à l'exploitation à la
valorisation de ces ressources en
Afrique il a été main de fois dit euh
mais les pays que les pays africains
sont riches de nombre de ces ressources
et de leur exploitation découle de
nombreux enjeux stratégiques économiques
sociaux comme environnementaux tout
d'abord comment évaluez-vous
l'importance de ces ressources dans le
développement économique des pays du
continent notamment au regard de
l'influence croissante de la Chine et
même de la Russie sur le secteur minier
en Afrique vous avez répondu à notre
peur Chine-Russie mais c'est sur la part
cro cissante de la main mise sur les
matières indispensables pour le futur
que je vous interroge enfin comment
envisagez-vous de renforcer le
renforcement pardon du partenariat
économique
franco-africain dans le domaine minier
permettant à la fois le développement
économique des pays du continent et de
la sécurisation des approvisionnements
français merci Monsieur buisson monsieur
Jolly merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre alors
l'opération à talante menée par la
France à Djibouti qui
vise à lutter depuis 2008 contre les
pirates qui pillent et qui freinent les
voies de passage commercial dans le
golfe d'Aden rencontent depuis plusieurs
mois de grandes difficultés puisque les
rebelles yéménites outil en conflit avec
l'Arabie Saoudite et qui sont soutenus
par l'Iran multiplie les attaques contre
les navires occidentaux il s'agit donc
pour la France de lutter contre des
attaques à caractère politique et non
plus contre des actes de piraterie
quelle est donc votre position monsieur
le Premier ministre sur l'évolution de
la situation à moyenen terme sur cette
zone commerciale d'une importance
stratégique majeure et sur la
possibilité euh envisager par la France
d'étendre l'opération Atalante à la
lutte contre la rbellion outil dans le
sillage des
États-Unis les merci é posé on va
essayer pour pas faire attendre trop le
taxi de de finir à 13h madame madame la
vice-présidente merci pour vos questions
les 18 pays ou 19 pays prioritaires en
fait on s' frranchit se trouve que c'est
les pays du siicide quoi du comité
interministériel puis après ça évolue en
de des réalités économiques et
donc voilà et et là effectivement les
pays francophones sont un tout petit peu
privilégié par rapport au au au pays où
il y a vraiment de l'investissement et
vraiment des échanges qui sont
malheureusement plutôt sur des économies
plus grandes hors de du champ et en
partie hors du champ du du suicide vous
avez dit est-ce que l'aide publique doit
rester une aide de subvention ou plutôt
de partenariat je crois tout le monde
est d'accord y compris d'ailleurs la
Commission européenne puisque elle a
débaptisé la direction générale du
développement une direction générale des
partenariat donc je crois que tout le
monde est d'accord que il faut faire du
partenariat d'égal à égal il faut
coinvestir que c'est beaucoup plus
efficace plutôt que de d'avoir une
action un peu
isolée et
individuelle plus on fait de choses dans
Team Europe probablement plus efficace
parce que pour le coup il y a aucun
doute que le principal invest ur
bailleur d'aide importateur et
exportateur pour toute l'Afrique c'est
l'Union européenne pas du tout la Chine
c'est l'Union européenne mais simplement
quand chaque fois qu'on compare la deuxè
puissance du monde avec 17000 milliards
de PIB à la France avec 3000 ou bien
avec la Roumanie si vous voulez
individuellement mais si on prend pas
quelque chose qui a le même poids que la
Chine c'estd l'Union européenne
évidemment l'Union européenne est de
loin le premier partenaire de la de de
de l'Afrique et donc si vous voulez team
Europe mais le problème c'est pas des
subventions c'est que l'aide française
et ça ça va nous nous comment dire nous
différencier négativement par rapport à
d'autres pays notamment les États-Unis
et la Grande-Bretagne qui sont monté en
puissance en aide publique ce sont des
prêts la FD c'est une banque elle est
régulée comme une banque elle a des
fonds propres de
banque beaucoup de pays et notamment
l'aide de l'Union européenne sont des
dons et donc la question c'est plutôt
comment le mix entre don et et d'te
fonctionne parce que si on est surtout
des cré des créanciers on va pas avoir
la même image et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que
la popularité est grande de l'Union
européenne parce qu'elle fait des dons
en fait alors tout le monde lui reproche
d'être extrêmement lente bureaucratique
de n'arriver à déper ses budgets que par
moi tellement elle est lente tout ça est
vrai d'ailleurs mais mais c'est des
dons et donc moi je pense que les dons
d'un côté et entre entreprise privé ou
publique mais entreprise les
partenariats et les co-investissements
c'est c'est c'est c'est le bon le bon
chemin sur l'annulation des dettes si
vous voulez on a créé un peu d'espace
sur la dette
bilatérale la Chine se fait une mauvaise
réputation en Afrique car elle est un
créancier avec laquelle est très
difficile de négocier le reprofilage
elle le refuse elle est observateur mais
pas acteur au Club de Paris et et donc
en fait l'Europe est assez exemplaire
sur les aides bilatérales sur les
multilatéraux on peut pas les reprofiler
et donc on peut pas or l'Afrique
subsaharienne est surtout endettée non
pas auprès des
marchés mais auprès des multilatéraux
mais vous avez pas le droit de prendre
du retard sur sur des remboursements FMI
Banque mondiale Banque africaine de
développement c'est des créanciers
privilégiés qui disent on perdrait notre
triple A si on commençait à reprofiler
donc malheureusementri sont humanitair
l'annulation des dettes c'est c'est du
bilatéral ça a été très efficace dans
les programmes PPTE c'estàdire de on a
échangé en fait des remboursements de
dettes et et on va faire pour le climat
la même chose dans lequel on pourra
plutôt que de rembourser un créancier
bilatéral faire des
investissements pour la transition
énergétique et ça tiendra lieu de
remboursement et ça c'est comme la
mécanique pays pauvre très endetté qui a
été en 2000 entre 2000 et 2005 une
bouffée d'air incroyable c'est un des
moyens de d'aide public au développement
les plus puissants mais on ne peut le
faire qu'avec les bilatéraux les
bilatéraux c'est la France c'est
l'Allemagne c'est les grande-bretagnes
c'est un peu les États-Unis assez peu la
Chine parce que en fait elle fait des
investissements elle fait du commerce
fait pas beaucoup d'aide publique au
développement bon c'est un peu rapide
excusez-moi je vais pas m'exprimer sur
le Bénin devant l'Assemblée nationale
française je suis désolé parce que je
considère que comme là pour le coup j'ai
joué un rôle politique important donc je
ferai pas de commentaire pour savoir si
j'ai été moi-même victime dans mes
droits d'opposants et je ferai pas de
commentair en France un territoire
français sur l'évolution de de mon de
mon pays le Bénin je pense c'est assez
différent de ce pourquoi vous m'avez
invité monsieur le monsieur le Président
je nous vous demandons certainement pas
il se trouve que ça a été une question
oui mais mais voilà sur le sur le
néolibibéralisme oui le néolibéralisme
si vous
voulez je crois pas qu'on soit des
économies très néolibéral en Afrique
parce qu'on n' pas le le luxe de l'êre
dans la mesure où on a secteur privé
très jeune je vous cacherai rien madame
la députée sur le fait que la
colonisation n'était pas faite pour
créer des entrepreneurs et un capital
autochtone et par conséquent on on a si
vous voulez on a grosso modo un secteur
privé africain qui date des
privatisations des la fin des années
90 on a le capitalisme le plus jeune le
plus faible du coup le plus fragile de
tous les capitalismes du monde parce que
franchement la
colonisation dans aucun
pays sauf dans les pays de peuplement
mais c'était pas les populations
indigènes
autochtones on n pas le le rôle de nos
états est considérable dans la
réglementation parce qu'il faut la créer
la législation parce qu'il faut la
créer on a reçu des pays ingérables en
dehors du fait qu'on avit pas de route
pas d'électricité pas de port on avit
pas de loi on avait pas
d'impôt les bonnes âmes nous disent mais
c'est quand même pas raisonnable vous
vous vous vous recollectez en impôt 18 %
du PIB alors que la France ça doit être
54 monsieur le Président pour du PIB et
la moyenne de l'OCDE 36 37 faites un
effort on a reçu une fiscalité
romaine de la capitation c'est ça qu'on
avait comme système en
1960 non
progressive enfin c'est incroyable donc
si vous voulez on on n' pas le lu d'être
extrêmement libéraux parce que
malheureusement on a énormément besoin
de de l'État il s'est simplement sorti
d'un certain nombre de secteurs
concurrentiel où il était il n'était pas
bon pas très efficace sur les ressources
monsieur le député faudrait presque
qu'on le fasse offline tellement elles
sont nombreuses si vous voulez mais le
problème si vous voulez c'est que des
ressources on est au début de
l'exploration bon dans mon pays on vient
de trouver du lithium du coltan et
cetera le BRGM son temps faisait un
travail de d'exploration on est très
loin d'avoir explorer toutes les
richesses mais on sait qu'en hydraulique
on est on a un potentiel considérable
dans les matières premièr critique aussi
et dans tout ce qui est agricole et
forestier on a un potentiel absolument
considérable tout ça est vrai et
celui-ci iste font en une base d'actif
oisif tant qu'on n pas de capital donc
notre problème si vous voulez c'est bien
d'avoir une une une une mine de lithium
ou comme les Guinéens les plus grands
gisement de boxit et de fer du monde
enfin si vous avez pas un chemin de fer
pour l'évacuer et un
port vous n'avez et puis des gens qui
ont investi dans la mine vous avez des
ressources oisives toute la question
c'est d'activer nos
actifs concernant la question monsieur
le député sur Atalante euh c'est dommage
que Madame la reporteur soit soit soit
parti mais vous pourrez lui dire
que c'est important de temps en temps
vous écoutez hein c'est intéressant de
quand même de parler des victoires
européenne vous avez une opération de
victoire contre la piraterie et de
sécurité dans le le détroit de
babelmondeb c'est
exceptionnel et essentiel pour le
commerce mondial vous avez d'ailleurs un
effort qui commence moindre ampleur mais
où la France est très présente dans le
Golf de Guinée où il y a aussi des
phénomènes de piraterie mais comme on
parle jamais des victoires mais
jamais si vous intéressez si vous
interrogez les Français disant Barkan ça
vous a laissé un goût amer mais alors
Atalante qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
personne connait Atalante quand vous
allez à Djibouti vous regardez le Yémen
à 19 km rendez compte que c'est quand
même relativement sensible vous avez
huit bases militaires la première et la
la base française historiquement mais ça
n'est plus ce n'est plus la plus grande
la plus grande c'est la Chinoise la
deuxième plus grande c'est l'américaine
mais vous avez la marine espagnole la
marine allemande vous avez euh
maintenant une base séouienne enfin bon
comprenez que c'est hypersensible comme
région Atalante n'était pas là euh pour
les outils c'était là contre les la
piraterie
somalienne mais ça peut tout à fait
s'utiliser en fait ce dispositif mais la
France et je l'approuve entièrement ne
veut pas qu'il y ait une extension du
conflit à toute la mer Rouge en créant
une coalition et c'est pour ça qu'elle
n'est pas au côté des États-Unis et des
Britanniques dans
l'opération pour assurer la sécurité
contre les missiles et les drones des
outils elle le fait et notamment elle
l'a fait récemment et d'ailleurs le
président de la République en a parlé
hier soir dans sa conférence de presse
mais elle n'est pas partie d'une
coalition de l'OTAN ou autre pour éviter
mais le président était très clairère et
moi je l'prouve entièrement que ce que
que qu' qu'on généralise mais
capitaliser sur la victoire d'Atalante
je vous assure c'est quelque chose qui
devrait être important mais cette espèce
de dilection moruse de la France pour ne
pas parler des succès et pour mettre
son ses échecs ou ses résultats en
demi-teinte en avant ça fait partie des
peurs françaises mais dans cette région
du monde la France est déterminante et
le réchauffement des liens avec
Djibouti a été opportun et le président
de la République française a été le
premier chef d'État français à se rendre
à djib outil et d'ailleurs il était le
premier à se rendre au Kenya mais sa
visite était importante en Éthiopie ses
deux visites au Nigéria on est loin du
précarré mais on est là dans des zones
où
l'influence progresse et de temps en
temps il y a de bonnes âmes et moi je
trouve que la paix des âmes c'est très
important qui se demande pourquoi le
président de la République française va
àjamena quand il y a le deuil du
président
euh Idris debi pourquoi il va à Djibouti
parce que il y a des réalités aussi dans
la relation Afrique France ou
afriquee les troupes chadiennes assurent
la
sécurité une partie du
Tchad du Nord du Cameroun de la zone de
maidouourri des des bookoaram de la
jaune de DIFA de la République du Niger
il se trouve que le Tchad est le pivot
de la sécurité de l'Afrique centrale et
a été
déterminant au Sahel les régiments
tadiens ayant été perçus comme les plus
puissants les plus efficaces contre les
djihadistes c'est juste une réalité de
fait partir de là pourquoi le président
de la République française va à Djibouti
parce que à
Djibouti on a la clé du en fait du canal
de suè qui est absolument essentiel au à
l'économie mondiale et qui est
fondamental pour les équilibres
militaires de temps en temps il faut
faire dans la relation africaine
France-Afrique autre chose que de la
psychologie autre chose que de la
sensiblerie et de temps en temps il faut
aussi regarder où sont les intérêts
vitaux il y a quelques pays qui
représentent c'est pour ça que votre
rapport était vraiment bienvenu
qui représente pour la France des
intérêts vitaux
merci merci voyez que la la symphonie
des adieux de ein se réalise les
derniers instrumentistes replient leur
leurs instruments à partir de 13h parce
que nous avons ces questions orales
maintenant de la séance du merc question
au gouvernement le le le mercredi et pas
seulement le mardi
c'est à 14h et et donc c'est c'est le le
le c'est très
moi je monsieur le Premier ministre je
vous ai pas appelé Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour la raison que vous avez
évoqué c'est que vous n'étiez pas là
pour parler au nom du Bénin et pour nous
exposer les les les les les relation
politique à l'intérieur du Bénin vous
étiez là comme citoyens français et
béninois expert des questions africaines
expert au combien au combien reconnu au
combien apprécié et je peux vous dire
même si on est maintenant monsieur petit
et moi les les deux seuls à à demeurer
dans cette dans dans cette salle je peux
vous dire parce que je connais mes
collègues et je sais ce que j'ai
ressenti moi-même que cette réunion que
vous avez animé était du plus a été
ressentie par chacun comme du plus haut
intérêt ça vraiment fait évoluer j'en
suis sûr fait bouger comme disent les
syndicalistes les la la représentation
que nos collègues se font de la relation
franco-africaine de la réalité africaine
tout simplement et de la des options
stratégique réel qui s'offre à un pays
comme le nôtre dans sa relation avec
l'Afrique ça a été vraiment une matinée
ex une séance une audition extrêmement
décapante ça ne m'a pas du tout surpris
ça ne m'a pas du tout étonné mais ça m'a
impressionné merci cher Lionel zinzou
d'être venu parmi nous et on verra votre
rapport c'est une affaire que que nous
suivons un peu on a reçu comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur pouyanet
qui qui qui a dirigé ça à sa manière son
audition assees en force comme nous le
connaissons euh mais toutes ces
questions autour de Total énergie sont
très présente à l'esprit de chacun ici
et je suis sûr que votre rapport donnera
là aussi
des éclairages qui seront nouveaux et
qui à ce titre mériteront d'être
considéré beaucoup d'intérêt merci en
tout cas au revoir cher Premier ministre
je vous
disten monsieur le député merci de votre
patience excusez-moi d'avoir été lent
mais je suis très honoré
d'avoir cétait inér à chaque fois que
mon chef de division à côté me disait
les horaires ne vont coll oui mais
comment voulez-vous que j'interrompe une
des observations qui sont du plus haut
intérêt que tout le monde dévore avec
avec gourmandise donc voilà il y a un
moment où il faut être vaincu fautac je
m'excuse d'avoir été aussi long présid
la séance n pas encore levée mais la
séance est levée
maintenant